Let's go baby!
Everybody is a tree.
Do you want to call MYK daddy?
No.
Don't talk about my coach that way!
Sensualize the coach!
Okay.
Who had the soundboard in their audio?
Who did that?
Why was it James who started that?
So yes, you'll be playing against everybody.
The round robin today is worth 3 points per match.
So if your team wins 3-2, let's say, you'll have won the round robin 9-6.
If your team somehow wins every match, you can win 15-0.
The round robin on Friday is worth 5 points per match.
So it's worth almost double.
Meaning that if you do well today, it's really good because you can secure a lead for Friday.
Friday is worth so much.
So really it's about how much you can improve from today to Friday and then take that improvement all the way to Sunday.
And then try to win in the bracket on there.
On Sunday, the rule will be the first team to 3 wins instead of the normal points.
So it'll have the traditional format we did last time.
But for the round robin, we wanted everybody to play because last time Scar's team died and he played twice out of 5 matches.
As an example.
So that was not fun for him.
So we figured it's more fun if everybody gets to play every match.
Not this time, baby!
Okay, I muted myself in Discord.
Don't say that to your team, bro.
By the way, are we allowed to stream with orientation?
I can't focus!
I'm not playing ranked because I'm scared.
I was like, if we weren't, well I'm so screwed.
I can't focus!
There's so many voices in my head!
That's very important about this.
Hello?
Can anybody hear me?
There's so many voices in my head!
They're a bit loud.
Okay, I'll turn them down.
Sound guy, are you here?
And you'll have downtime between matches because when you're not playing...
There's too many.
There's too many voices in my head!
You have time.
Okay, I brought down the Discord volume.
You have some time there.
Everybody will be playing at the same time.
One thing that's important is that...
I can't just ignore them!
The exceptions are people who are not playing on PC.
Those are the people who like...
Okay, I turned them down.
Sorry, guys.
We go straight into rules.
So that's gonna be a little odd.
But if you are not playing on PC, just let RTOs know.
And then we can get that figured out.
And you can get added by your coach.
If you're a coach, I'm gonna stream real quick.
And show you how to make the lobby in a really easy way.
And if anybody else wants to watch, it'll probably make it easy for you.
It's so good.
Yeah, there's a really simple way to do it.
That's really nice.
So let me share my screen real quick.
I did the copy-paste thing.
Guys, this might be the old PC.
But I don't crash anymore.
Guys, guys!
I did unpack the PC!
I just... I just didn't plug it in.
Any place near your house.
It can be a burrito or a burrito bar.
It's so good!
So the way this works...
Oh, I missed it.
If you haven't done this before, is when you go to player match, and create the room.
And then one thing I would advise is putting on a coat.
Under advanced settings.
Oh, God.
Please.
Have mercy.
I'm new.
I would also recommend adding simultaneous rooms.
This is so that if your team wants to practice while you play, you can practice.
Then you click create session.
Oh my God, he ducks!
He plays against kings!
Important thing.
The main match and whoever is playing next should always be in group A.
Please do not be like, oh, my teammate just started his match.
I'm gonna go play on group B or one of these other places.
And then hold up the event.
I will make fun of you a lot.
Everybody will make fun of you.
Please don't hold up the event.
If you're gonna play next...
Yeah, go for it.
Can you please, on record, state that I'm not a player?
No!
That's right, you can't duck that!
I don't know.
I played him and he was wifi'd.
So...
You gotta post the picture for proof.
No, please stop!
I got the vibe.
So, if you take a peek at my screen here.
You see shift tab, you see this overlay here.
The easiest way to invite people is you click friends.
Click your little profile picture here.
Yay, fight or flight!
And then you go to where it says join game.
You just click copy link address.
And when you post it, someone can just post it in their browser and they'll automatically join your lobby.
Okay, but what if I do this?
That's like one of the only thing I can do.
And I...
Please!
I'm sorry!
You can't duck this!
And if anybody's on console, just let the TOs know.
And they'll handle that.
Okay, another question.
Did you get bonus points for playing an honest character like Dragunov?
Alright, so hopefully you've all enjoyed that.
Thank you!
I'll be interviewing some coaches and stuff.
Good luck, good luck everybody.
Thank you!
Bye!
Good luck, have fun!
I actually said that on live television.
I can't believe it.
Very nervous.
I came into this thinking y'all were dudes.
And I was running to take you out the end of the chair.
No!
He did duck!
Okay.
I was like what the fuck did y'all sign me up for?
Nice.
Yeah, we good.
Did everybody leave yet?
I can't tell.
I'm too busy in the game.
I'm so sad.
Blue rings and stuff.
I'm like what's going on?
I should have swapped up the first one.
He's just better.
I'm sorry.
Don't watch my videos then.
Because I've not processed anything in this orientation.
Signify, can you meet me?
Is everybody still in the VC?
Oh shit, everybody left!
That's a lot.
Did I lose real quick?
They're gonna be scared for sure.
I'm gonna lose real quick.
No, no, no, no.
No, don't lose.
No, no, no.
You wanna keep the 13 win streak, dude.
No, I don't because they're gonna play me differently.
They're like oh my god, I'm gonna play scared and I'm not gonna predict it.
I would rather they play me no knowledge whatsoever.
Come on, man.
I think that's just putting it all out on the table, you know?
We'll see.
It worked for me last time.
I had a 20 win streak last slam.
I decided to throw it so it didn't say that I had it.
Someone in the chat saying they don't save from quick match.
I don't know anything about it though.
Uh, oh shit.
Well, whatever.
I don't know anything about it.
So they want all the coaches to make a lobby?
Yeah, you make a lobby and then I guess just post it.
And then...
How big?
Like max or...
I don't know.
I don't know either, bro.
Yo, good shit yesterday.
Alright.
Good shit is a crazy thing to say about yesterday.
What do you mean?
I saw that adaptability, bro.
A key charge?
Don't worry about that.
But you did good.
I watched the whole thing.
It was fucking sick.
I didn't catch it.
Bro, first set you got third, right?
Yeah.
That's pretty good.
I'll tell you something, Kony.
I mean, you know this better than most.
You go for something like an offstage balcony punch.
And then it goes south.
And then it goes to game five.
Yeah, you were awake, right?
3 AM thinking about that punch.
That's all I'm saying.
I feel it.
It was a one-to-one equipment.
Well, Bear has a lot of people like him, right?
Like, I'm gonna be really funny and then spit on my back a lot and then Dragon off punches you in the fucking skull.
And you're like, oh.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was bad.
Not gonna lie.
I saw you tweet whoops.
So I assumed that's what that was.
Yeah, that was.
Also, hi Doki.
I don't think we've met.
Hey!
My fingers are not used to playing this early in the morning.
That's how I'm feeling, dude.
I've been playing Tekken at 11 PM.
Doki, it is 6 PM on the East Coast.
That's too early for Tekken.
Not too early for Coast.
That's crazy.
Tekken is 3 AM vibes.
I respect it.
Tekken is a night game, not a morning game.
I'll shake on that.
That's absolutely true.
I'm so, I'm so fucked.
I saw the intel report and I felt like everybody had Tekken experience in the newbie categories.
Except for me.
Don't worry.
All for free.
I'm here for the moral support, guys.
I'm here for the moral support.
You did hit an RDC on the computer.
I know, right?
That was so hard to do.
I hope they stand still for me to do the RDC.
Yeah, the rate of play is like way higher on this one.
Even the lower ranks is like...
I don't know.
People are taking this stuff seriously.
You're gonna learn that the king has a 70% chain throw.
We'll teach you that for the second and third one.
They probably won't know how to break.
Like in game.
We should teach them that.
Get ready for the next battle.
Tony, I saw you on your little ass alt stream last night.
Yeah, what are you doing lurking in my side stream?
I linked them, dude.
My bad.
I didn't know you had a little team that has little ass stream.
Little ass no cam.
I need to do a gameplay side stream where my viewers go half.
You can't play Tekken on the real stream.
Wait, I don't understand.
The link is up for the lobby?
I mean, I made one.
I don't know if they wanted me to.
But you said that I should.
So, I did.
Check the stage 3 chat.
They asked you to.
Okay.
Oh, it's in the fucking chat.
I'm stupid.
Hopefully I did it correctly.
I'm gonna play one quick match and then join after it.
Cause I'm poor at seed.
Maybe I should just play Eddy.
Match 3.
I promise you it'll get us through this first round.
Nobody trained for Eddy, right?
It says I need a passcode?
It's 0009.
Alright, now you just stole the whole stream.
So, fuck.
Come on, everybody in.
They don't have the link.
Join it up and pretend to be me so I don't have to play.
Wait, wait.
I did it wrong, guys.
I made it wrong.
That's cause you're 40 years old, man.
You're older than I am.
I like what you said the other day.
The other day it's like my nephew who is older than me.
Hold on.
I'm telling them I didn't make categories.
Is that okay?
Alright, I can remake it dude.
I can remake it.
Not my chat is making fun of me.
Oh my god this is going to be a horrible day.
The average age of this Tekken team is 46.
Wait, what?
Youtubers are young forever.
So maybe like 5?
So I'll bring down the average, don't worry.
Together, assembled, we are a young spry 22 year old.
Oh my gosh, we can go to bars!
Yeah, for the first time.
Oh my god!
We won't get carded!
Wow, they're getting right into this, huh?
Yeah, we're just going to go I guess.
Wait, you guys are in the lobby now?
Wait, I'm not in there.
Wait!
Wait, I'm fucking in a quick thing!
Don't worry, I'll die soon.
I'm going to get destroyed.
My lobbies are just broken.
I don't know.
It's just not...
Okay, someone else needs to make it.
Did we really let MYK do it?
Yeah.
The smarter person.
I mean, but he lost.
He lost!
Maybe he was overthinking.
Oh!
He's so smart and you're so dumb.
True.
I didn't say all of that.
How the fuck does my game say online mode unavailable?
This is like the worst timing.
Hold on.
I know you're coming in.
I know they were doing some maintenance stuff last night because I was playing and they were just...
You guys know.
It was like...
No, that happens to everyone occasionally where it'll kick you off like that.
Oh.
Yeah, for some reason.
I had to be in school today.
Dude, that was smart.
I'm in my mid-thirties.
I haven't done long division in half my life.
What's up?
So, anyone else threw up due to nerves or is that just me?
I know how bad I'm gonna do so I'm not nervous at all.
Wait, why is my PC not working?
I think I gotta like restart my PC or something.
My online mode is not working.
I know my place.
Can you just restart again?
I did just now.
Get ready for the next battle.
Oh, I think I was offline on Steam for some reason.
I'll try again.
How do I join the lobby?
So, do you see that link in the stage 3 event?
Yeah.
Just post that on your browser.
I have a browser?
Oh, on my Steam?
What did you think I meant?
I was like, oh my god, Tekken has browsers I can just post it in?
I'm gonna restart my PC.
Like a Chrome in Tekken.
I feel that.
I was like, oh my god.
I just got Tekken Chrome.
Oh, this really is the blunt rotation group.
That's how we described this.
Now I know what it means.
I think we got a strong blunt rotation.
How do I paste this?
Guys, give me a second.
Just paste it in the URL.
I think.
Oh, I pasted the wrong one.
Sorry.
Okay.
We're gonna get DQ'd if you guys keep this up.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to figure it out.
Coach, I did the right thing.
Coach.
How to paste.
Control V, I think.
I can just copy.
Should I?
Who's up first?
Is it?
It's a Doki, right?
It's Doki.
It's me.
It both left me.
I'm trying.
I'm launching.
I swear.
I swear to god.
Okay, I'm in.
I'm in.
We made it.
I did it.
I swear to god.
It took me so long.
Let's fucking go.
Can I restart my PC?
Hello?
Matt's PC is dying.
I've lost my anchor.
No, bro.
No, no, no.
I just don't know.
It won't connect to online the moment I launch.
It says online is unavailable.
Oh.
Oh, it's good.
It's good.
Oh, everybody is.
Everything is going wrong.
It's fine.
I gotta use the bathroom.
Oh my god.
No, don't leave me here.
Okay, but what if I just go Eddie?
Do it against Gummy.
Do it.
What if I just go Eddie?
She won't know what to do.
How do I stay in the right side?
What do I press?
Toggle stay.
J?
Why is it J?
Why can't I ready up?
Click on your screen.
Maybe you're like tabbed out or something.
No.
Oh my god.
This is...
This is so much.
I can't even ready up.
You hit the left kick button to ready up.
Hell yeah.
Well, it's now Keishin.
Hello.
Why am I downloading?
I don't want to download.
Oh.
There you go.
I accidentally was on the chat screen.
That's why.
Let's go.
Lobby created.
Okay.
We did it.
The first hurdle is done.
Okay.
Do I do it?
Do I pull out the King... the Eddie?
That's the kind of beast mode.
Hit her with the 3 Eddie.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Let's see if she learned how to play against Eddie.
That's so great.
Get ready for the next battle.
You got this.
Well, I only know one move on him.
That's all you need.
And all your ancestors.
Oh, here.
Hit the theme song.
Play number one.
You know how to rage her.
Oh, no.
She knows how to rage her.
She knows.
She figured it out.
How?
Yo, is anyone else streaming this?
It says I'm unable to speak.
I'm streaming it.
Oh, shit.
She's a better streamer than me.
I'm a YouTuber.
Alright.
Let's watch.
Oh, my gosh.
She actually fucking think count.
Learned the Eddie calendar after I fucked with her.
I actually don't know this character, you know.
Boom.
3-3-3.
It's real.
3 -3-3.
Do it for the boys at Brio.
Yeah.
There we go.
Do it again.
Bazinga.
Level two Bazinga?
What the fuck is going on?
I don't know.
I lost track of him.
Hey, drop her.
Oh, God.
Oh, no.
How am I supposed to do the Eddie's if she juggles me?
Nice try, nice try.
Oh, you just hit the three button.
The three button?
Yeah, the three button right there.
Yeah, like that!
I mean, Cody might be in.
Cody might be in.
Oh my gosh.
Where's our life at?
We all saw the 30 button, it worked all the way up until, what, like, Red Rex?
Because Orange, it'll work.
Oh my gosh!
I'm gonna die again!
Let's go!
My read for you is you walk up and you press three.
Okay, okay, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Don't worry, I got it.
Get that third button off the controller.
Oh, she's blocking my...
No!
Oh my god!
That's a dev tip.
That's a developer difference.
That's not fair at all.
That's not fair!
She's hacking!
That's Hirata's fault.
Let me just say, punishing a flash with a rage art is the most next level shit ever.
Oh, mate.
Unironic.
Wait, how do I swap characters?
How do I do it?
Oh, fuck.
I'll be like, sorry, I picked the wrong character.
Raven has a one frame counter.
Sorry, picked the wrong character.
Picked the wrong character.
I didn't know.
Sorry, wrong input.
It's not as...
Picked the wrong character.
Slime, you gotta sit on the sides, brother.
We have, um...
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Oh, me too, me too, me too.
My bad, my bad, my bad.
Everybody's trying to get in.
It's just weird.
Slime is coming in.
Yeah.
Big bro's gonna handle this one.
Step aside.
Pass the controller.
It's okay, let me call somebody real quick.
I said it's my turn.
She's a phone-a-friend.
Phone-a-friend.
King.
Get ready for the next battle.
I won't be surprised if I do worse.
No.
Because I have to actually think.
I don't see that happening.
This is like warming up before working out.
That's true, that's true.
The idea was just to warm up and now we're gonna hit PR.
That's true.
That thing is so cute.
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck is she doing with that little...
Getting very dizzy.
Oh shit.
Yup, that's a duck.
Oh no, she ducks!
I can't believe it.
It's like she knows she's playing good for her.
That's the king!
Round two.
You gotta throw your best mids.
Oh god.
Oh my god, she's so fast!
I think the armor runs out.
Oh my god.
She ducks everything.
Her ass is holding down.
Oh, that's fun!
That's right, that's right.
I'm gonna teach you so many good mids.
Yeah, for tomorrow.
Yeah, watch this.
This is all...
We're just throwing because we all know this one doesn't matter.
That's true, that's true.
That's true.
It's too early for this for me.
Wait.
My hands are definitely not warmed up.
It's too early.
That was counter hit.
Oh my god, A!
Oh no, not the smith!
Not the smith!
I'm in!
You're in!
It's not really fair though.
She did have a sword.
You know what I'm saying?
That's true, that's true.
Why would you bring a sword to a fist fight?
Or a baguette.
That's not fair.
That's true.
Is it all best of five?
I think it's first to two like last time.
It's just a round robin so it shouldn't be too long.
Right, right.
You said pick the wrong character.
I just saw that.
I'm just gonna pick the one I like.
Yo, I gotta take a leak.
I'll be right back.
Oh my god, finally.
I can chill now.
For like 15 minutes maybe.
I don't have to do anything.
Yay!
Toggle.
I'm just gonna do a king mirror.
King mirror.
You're actually...
Wait, what's this person you're playing ranked?
Uh...
Purple.
Same rank.
You just have so many years, Kony.
That's the thing.
He has more years than me.
You gotta understand.
As old as I am, it's James Chen, bro.
Wait, this is...
You're playing James Chen?
He has more years than I could dream of.
You're playing SuckMyNutsAsshole's James Chen?
Yes, it's that guy.
It's the guy.
Oh my god.
I don't like that.
The James Chen.
Not me neither.
But that's the hand we're dealt.
The matchups are hard this one.
I believe in you.
Do I pick random stage?
I don't know how stage works here.
I think you're supposed to pick random.
That's what I did the entire time.
It's like in the rules that are really fucked.
How about the farm another James Chen clip like the last one?
Just...
If I can make him do that again, we're good.
Oh my god, he's a cowboy.
He is.
This is the... it's a star is born king.
I don't know which king is which.
Which one is king?
Our guy is a cowboy.
Let's go cowboy.
Oh!
This is a real king match.
Yippee!
Let's go.
I tried to duck it.
Oops.
No, I'm trying to do this.
Genius block.
There we go.
Yeah, the knee bash.
Hell yeah.
Oh!
Yup.
Oh my god.
I can tell that you actually know what you're doing.
Mmm, okay.
That's a nice round start.
It's a good gimmick.
I Atlas have.
I have never jacked round start all the time.
Yeah.
That shit is fucking nice actually.
Boom!
Okay.
You know what?
I should pick up king.
That's cool.
Yeah, we should all end up playing king in the end.
The final is...
I'll play king.
We all just bring out the king.
I'd be so down.
Fucking go.
Let's fucking go.
Good shit.
Round four.
Fight!
Oh!
That counter hit was sick.
Boom!
Okay.
Alright, I got it.
I got it.
You're my fucking goat.
You know that shit?
Whoa!
After the knee pony, he's always like crouch jabbing every time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's scared of that grab.
Boom!
Hop kick.
You're right.
Yeah.
Yeah, knee hop kick for a free combo.
This one.
Next one.
Ah!
That was supposed to be what he did, but I did the shoulder because I didn't get the neutral.
Mmm!
Oh no.
That was...
That was so much damage.
Okay.
Yeehaw!
Yee-haw!
I got it.
Round two.
Double low.
That's crazy.
Oh, we gotta be here a little faster.
Just a little bit.
Yeah, just pretend that's my king in three days.
I believe.
Alright, he doesn't block this, but he does block the next one, which means we grab.
Oh my god!
He didn't.
Okay, whatever.
Alright, take the ground.
Okay.
Yeah.
I keep getting that.
I tried to duck, but I got locked in.
I'm trying to duck, but I got locked in.
At the fucking mirror.
He's so scared of you.
Yeah.
He's dead.
God, you're fucking nice with it, man.
I got it.
Let's go.
Do not doubt the goat.
I'm confident.
Okay.
Dude, that round start launcher, I'm gonna steal that.
That shit was...
That's a really good fucking up and down.
Yeah.
That's really unsafe, though.
You can hop kick it if you block it.
If I pop that one round at six or nine, I'm cool with it.
You know what I mean?
I do that on ranked every single day of my life.
One half this hammer per rank.
Round start.
It's really strong.
I mean, it's gonna crush any highs and shit, you know?
Yeah, and they won't expect it.
Because you didn't pull it out before.
Exactly.
Just for the one time.
Whoops.
Who's next?
Should be Slime versus Fission, I think.
Alright.
It's my turn, right?
James Chen has some words for you.
Did he just tweet this?
Suck my nuts at dude.
What the fuck?
It's a fun game.
Frame one.
What the fuck is his problem, man?
That's my goat.
Okay.
Why'd he say assholes?
I was the one that beat...
What?
Can I get a link to that?
Do you not know the tweet?
If you look...
If you search James Chen suck my nuts assholes and go through the timeline Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's very beautiful.
I feel like if you just search James Chen tweet, it'll come up.
Like, that's his legacy.
You know what I mean?
Am I ready to start?
Doki, you have to hit the right trigger.
Hit the rage art button.
Rage art button?
Oh, okay.
See, that's...
I mean... Oh, why am I not on the game?
Coach Matthew.
Let's go.
I was like, why am I always back in the game?
Here we go.
Damn, this guy's a Tekken king.
What happened?
What's going on?
Wait, he's Tekken king?
How?
Why?
I didn't know about this.
I'm afraid about it.
Remember, Slime, I had to beat an Azu Sinne to get God of Destruction on Kuma, so...
You got this.
It's very doable.
Why the fuck is their fourth seed lower?
They're ranked in the third seed.
No, dude.
Also, I can't spectate any of these matches.
Watch my stream.
No, watch my stream.
Give me the views.
Okay, give... Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't even know how to navigate streams on YouTube.
For real.
Wait, just press go to Doki Bird's YouTube channel.
Wait, she's naked.
Stop the match.
Oh my goodness.
Wait, wait, wait.
Not allowed.
Put on some clothes, young lady.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna get destroyed here.
Damn.
Patient.
Nice.
Lot of block.
That's a double.
Nice.
Okay.
I did not prepare this matchup, I'll say it.
Round two.
Okay, we're just not showing them the strats.
Exactly.
It's just round robin one.
We still have round robin two.
Nice.
It's not guaranteed.
Okay, that's fine.
I thought the butt was guaranteed.
No.
Not after the... It needs to be a higher wall splat.
Break the guitar.
I'm sad that her guitar is covering her ass.
I...
The sad day.
At least fully commit.
Good shit.
What a hopkick, dude.
He's simply better.
Raid right here.
Mish, get the chip.
Oh.
Nah.
Yes.
Good shit.
Not a rage art.
At least not immediately.
Woo!
Fight.
Good shit.
We can take chip.
We can bounce.
Grab it.
Yeah.
Every time.
Nice.
She loves that string, huh?
Yeah.
There we go.
Game one, baby.
Dude, lots of grabs.
Lots.
Because like...
She's scared of you.
Not breaking them.
Yeah.
Just keep feasting, bro.
Feast.
Good shit.
I gotta restart my game.
She might adapt.
Round one.
Oh, I gotta go get a... for a coach interview.
A coach interview?
Come on.
Alright.
I'll be back.
Good shit.
We have damage.
I always grab it with the health sweep.
It's a little predictable.
She didn't let go on that.
Nice.
Don't worry about...
Don't overthink it.
Because like...
I don't know if they're at that level yet.
She is starting to break grabs though.
Good shit.
Nice.
I like the idea.
Love that string.
Geez.
Alright, I'm gonna do five.
Oh, power crush does beat that.
She's cool.
Nice.
Copy pressing.
Appreciate it.
That's a punish.
Oh, jeez.
There we go.
Good shit.
Yes!
Big, big, big.
Just purely big.
That's all it is.
You're reading his mind!
Good shit.
I like the idea.
She's giving you all the space in the world, dude.
Good break.
I just keep power crushing.
It's gonna work sometimes.
Yeah, the damage is worth it.
Good shit.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna wake up right here.
It'll work.
I think I get this.
I think you get this.
Yes!
You get it?
Is this ever explained in lore or do we just still not know?
Oh man.
It's just a fish that's a missile.
Understood.
My fault.
Those are in the wilderness.
It's just a bear with a fish missile.
How is that launch?
What happened?
That's a weird launcher.
It doesn't even look like a counter.
Nice job.
I'm getting destroyed.
It's okay.
We just wanted to get it close, you know?
A lot of skins.
Matterhorn?
Oh, it doesn't work.
I'm dead.
That's fair.
It's alright.
It's just the anticipation.
I'm power crushing!
Oh, I got fucked up, man.
Oh, I had it.
It's one round.
It's all good.
Shit.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Not eating... She's not eating the power crushers anymore.
I think I gotta have a better mix-up game off of the coin bear stance.
Sorry,
I'm just so delayed.
I apologize.
We got a circle.
Nice.
Oh, nice hit!
Good shit.
Yeah!
Two more big dog.
Got this.
She read me there.
Ah, fuck.
It's fine.
We're gonna get that back.
Ah!
I keep getting...
Just... lots of jmes.
When you get in heat slime you can grab her or something.
Because he is just holding back.
It's a bare electric.
He is doing very good at playing outside grab range now.
Let's f***ing go dude!
Nice hit.
Wait for the whiff here.
Move!
I don't know what she is doing to me.
She is showing all the cards out now.
I think I punish this.
Let's f***ing go!
Yes!
Wow!
That was an intense match.
That was such a good game.
Good f***ing game.
Nice hit.
You're better!
Oh my god, that was so hard.
That guy was very good at playing outside grab range.
Like, that was really good spacing.
He adapted, that's why it was so scary.
Yeah.
He's not free.
Yeah, but he showed off the most dirty of his moves today.
Well yeah, we got extreme downloads happening right now.
Good shit, dude.
Let's go home!
I think you got more info there than he did.
Like, straight up.
If we're talking about reviewing sets, because he's on his back foot the whole set.
Like, you're constantly aggressing and pushing, and he's just, like, in reverse, you know?
Yeah.
Now we just get to watch Jack Jesus cook.
Yeah, now we just sit back and relax.
Now we get to watch him win every round, right?
Yeah, right?
Let's put all the pressure on him.
Bruh.
My savior.
Clutch your kick.
Bruh.
Yeah, I don't really want to play.
So, please win this.
I mean, I have to play anyway.
You can't do that anymore.
Clutch your kick!
No, dude, that tiebreaker was so fucked up for my mental.
I've never been under so much pressure.
Lay awake at night.
What the fuck is this Skara skin?
It's so ugly!
It's there to distract you of how ugly it is.
No, that's the Odd Future Supreme job, bro.
That's the Odd Future Supreme job, bro.
I'm dressed like a 50-year-old YouTuber.
This is such a strange... you know what I mean?
Like a guy who's like trying to exploit the algo, you know?
Like...
He's got his kids singing songs.
You break throws?
I break throws!
Let's go.
Hey-oh.
I didn't do that to be honest with you, but you know.
But it works.
That ship is crazy.
Bruh, still.
Oh my god, what a...
Oh my god.
Count for me, Jack.
Count for me.
I forgot how to count, bro.
Let's go!
Let's hit that thing.
I thought that would work, but I guess not.
No way he doesn't.
Oh, he knows Skara.
Good to know.
That's all I need to know.
Nice launch.
Stop that nonsense, dude.
That's one of the sins.
Woo!
I'm back!
Uh-oh.
You're chasing it down!
Oh my god.
Nice!
Oh!
Got him back!
Drop the satellite!
Yeah!
Stab you in the foot.
Drop the satellite.
Oh, fuck.
He doesn't even wear shoes.
Oh, man.
I'm so sorry.
Skara got pretty good.
What the fuck?
I know, right?
That's what I'm saying.
I swear to god it's not me.
He's actually good.
Oh, just Viktor.
Woo!
Yes!
Nice!
Viktor Gamma House.
People actually improving?
No way.
They're supposed to stay at the level they are.
Oh my god.
No!
You contended.
You have it.
I thought we were friends.
You're continuing the string.
Oh!
No.
I'm so sorry.
That's all right.
Don't stress it.
That string is too long.
That's all right.
We're just giving him one.
You know?
Oh.
Nice fucking read on the power crush.
Every time I think the combo is over, there's another off the ground.
Where did his health go?
Oh.
That code did not offer any protection.
Get a helmet.
Oh, man.
This is.
I just want to.
Shoot your gun.
A satellite.
Oh that's hitting?
Oh.
So it is ten frames.
Be safe!
Oh, my.
Yes.
Why are you doing that, bro?
Why?
Why are you doing that?
Don't listen to the coach bro.
You don't know what you're doing.
You don't even make Tekken content.
You can't even upload that anywhere.
I'm sorry.
He's not even creating content, he likes that move!
Whaaat?
Oh...
Fuck.
Bon appetit, bro.
Damn, Skrull.
Oh my god.
That was too long!
It never stopped!
I get kinda bored during these combos.
They're too long- Oh wait!
No, this one's kinda good actually!
Oh!
Wait!
This one's kinda hype!
Tekken's back!
Oh, he went to the crest!
Oh man, this is wall.
Are we going all the way?
This is a good ass combo.
Send him to the emperor!
Take a Michelle Kong, bro!
Bruh.
Oh my god, he could do a bathroom break with that combo.
Oh, I'm talking about that.
Uh oh.
Bro, I saw James Chan and was inspired.
Fuck.
Wow.
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck was that?
It's freaky Jack 8.
That has to be a new move.
That's a hot patch.
What if Jack 8, but freaky?
Oh my god, Matt.
Okie, okie.
Oh shit.
Let's go.
This dude is studying the move list.
What the fuck?
Whoops.
He's bringing his Kre-eeta character into the match.
Tekken literally add that move just for him.
I hate Tekken players.
What a...
Dude, you're goaded.
That was spacing beautifully.
Beautiful.
Look at that!
He killed it!
Oh wow.
That's such a good move.
But how long does it go Matt?
How long do we need to hit it?
Surely not more!
Oh no, you're spacing is inspiration.
Really?
One more mix.
Guess for game, Scarra!
Guess for your life!
Guess for your fucking game!
Let's go dude.
All hail, all hail.
That was so beautiful.
What a good round of tech.
That was insane.
What a fucking freak!
He's showing moves none of us have seen before.
Guess for the fucking game bro.
What was that?
I've never seen that in Tekken.
The what one?
The slider.
The one where you just jumped on top of him.
Oh yeah, you know.
Just buffed up moves that never exist.
I patched the game so I could put those moves in.
You gotta call the devs and add that in.
Custom finisher.
I got the Mii Brawler.
Alright.
We got the God's Kingdom clutch.
I mean, we take this easy.
Let's be real.
We beat his ass here coach.
He's good man.
He's good.
You beat him before.
Yeah, what happened?
Where's your confidence?
Alright, hold on.
That shit still works.
It got a destruction.
That's his default now.
Is it?
Is the cape also?
My king never looked like that.
Yeah, my king didn't have that cape.
Oh, you know what?
I think it's Tekken 7.
Like a...
It's a priest net.
Bear?
How good is this guy's bear?
I've never seen him.
Is he God of Destruction?
I mean, yeah, he's God.
I think MWIK is like a bunch of characters.
Yeah, Unk has a crazy weird face.
I can learn some shit.
Okay.
Look at that.
Oki.
That's new.
Oh!
Wow.
I've never seen that before.
I think it's guaranteed now after the buffs.
I actually got a replay though.
That happened to me once.
Why are they showing everything in just round robin one?
Okay, we're getting hit by G-Clust.
Doesn't look good for Unk.
Wow.
Okay.
Slidy ass bear.
What the fuck?
This bear is oiled up.
Roll into...
Nice.
Good adaptation.
You're not eating any of his bullshit.
The Dao Bag 2 is on us there.
Nice.
Good shit.
Can I just say something?
They have Akuma on their team.
And I beat their Azucena.
Just saying.
Damn it.
He just beat it.
Yeah, he was.
Nice.
Dude, that rolled butt.
Whatever the fuck it is.
That's crazy.
That's a good move.
Yeah, that's the first time I'm seeing that too.
We're gonna apply that to you, Slime.
Yeah, I feel like in heat, he has even more shit now.
Yeah.
And the chip damage remover.
Whatever the fuck they call it.
How did Akuma do on the last pet?
Akuma got some buffs.
Kanda got even more.
Damn it.
Oh.
I missed a stop.
Mikey's getting his revenge.
All he had to do was use a bear.
That is crazy.
Oh, I had never stopped.
Fight.
That's the thing about Tekken combos.
I'd just be taking 40.
You know what?
He showed his hand too early.
We know now of this jutsu.
We know all this shit.
But then he's gonna play Fang on Friday.
He got mad characters, bro.
That's not his main?
He mains everyone for some fucking reason.
He mains everyone?
Ankh's got a couple...
players or characters too.
We can play Paul for the lore.
Here we go!
Oh.
Oh, you can't parry that.
I tried to low parry it like an idiot.
That's not low parryable?
No.
Nice.
We know that.
We see it every time.
Bounce.
Nice.
And we got the leg.
Oh!
Holy shit.
Alright, end this now.
Yeah!
Stop the combos!
It's as simple as that.
You just bring it back.
Easy.
Just hit him.
Oh.
Damn.
Oh, that move's so good.
Oh, nice.
Let's get some life.
Just making it close for the stream.
Oh!
That was close.
Nice.
Bear's pretty good.
Yeah.
Yeah, you saw how that back wall pushed too.
I couldn't really do anything.
You know what I mean?
It's okay.
We can use this and give it to slime.
Yeah.
No, this is...
I just gave us info.
Oh, slime info.
Appreciate it.
Freaking dude.
Also, we still won more points.
3-2.
We got it.
Yeah, we went positive on the round.
Yeah.
Thanks for the carry.
Thanks for the carry, guys.
Thanks for the trip to Eden.
This is like watching your dad lose a fight at the bar.
The moral support, guys.
Is there like an intermission between rounds?
Or do we go straight into the next one?
As far as I know, I guess we can.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, I don't have the bracket.
Please keep your lobby open.
Are we staying here?
Oh.
Well, we would leave.
Because if we keep the lobby open, then whoever hosted it would stay.
So, I think we leave no matter what.
Oh, I thought we made it.
Okay.
Hold on.
My chat sent me a clip of James Chen raging against me.
I gotta go watch that.
I mean, obviously you gotta ego boost every now and then.
Show it to us.
That sounds very fun.
Hold on.
Paste the link.
Okay, guys.
You guys come in here when you're watching me with absurdly low expectations.
It's in the chat, don't be.
We are the moral support.
We know my place.
Everybody knows my place here.
I am literally the moral support.
We have the same reaction.
Hahaha.
Okay, I should be leaving the lobby.
Why am I still here?
Uhh, this is the clip.
I'm glad I am here!
I am glad to be here.
Hahaha.
Alright, let me see this clip.
Hahahahaha!
Are you guys speaking...
Are you guys speaking the clip?
Yeah, yeah.
He's just hitting buttons.
Bro, he was true though.
He was spitting.
At that point...
I've been him.
I was him last night against a Hwoarang and a Lee and a Lars.
Like, I get it.
He's right.
Bro, he's just hitting buttons.
At that point in the set, I was like, we go shoulder into R1.
Fuck it.
We just...
Just everything out.
All in on this.
I shouldn't go into a match in case the lobby goes back up.
Well, I jumped into rank just to make sure I'm warmed up and stuff.
True.
I'm gonna continue.
I'm gonna do a quick match.
Okay, then I have time then.
If you're all in a quick match, then I can't be blamed.
Yeah.
We're in it together.
What are you gonna do?
Disqualify us?
We cannot do that.
Full team knocked out.
Yeah, full team knocked out because we're in quick play.
So I'd rather be in quick play than this.
I'm gonna go into the tournament.
Sorry, guys.
All right, guys.
I'm gonna mask off.
I am so fucked.
I know how to do combos.
It's probably gonna take a little while.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
I know how to do combos, but I can't implement it into the game.
Like, I know how to do that.
I don't understand.
Why can't my fingers do this in the real game?
I do block.
Did he stop panic?
I do.
It's just that I stopped blocking because I was like, I can out hit.
Why is he red rank playing against me?
It's a quick match.
I will show you replays of me doing it.
I swear to God.
Oh shit, sorry.
Sometimes my hands are in the wrong position too.
I think that's also my issue.
Oh my God, what the fuck?
What are you doing?
Here you go.
Fuck off old man.
I feel like he does that shit and it scares me.
There we go.
No!
Stop!
I just stuck new!
No duck.
He ducked.
Oh my God.
It's like he plays this game more than me.
Bro, I have fucking two days of experience on this fucking game.
If you lose a set from me, you're fucking terrible.
If you lose one round off of me.
You're so bad.
Imagine being red rank and losing at one round from a fucking person who has three days of experience.
What is this play for?
You're so fucking bad.
Imagine being red rank and losing that.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
Stop staying on the ground and get up!
What the fuck?
I mean, she's got the play.
Okay.
Goodbye.
I'll never touch you again.
What?
Dude, a lying grappa.
There.
You like that grappa?
Is that what you mean?
Whoa.
Oh God.
Please let me do this move.
Please!
She's so...
It's a quick match!
Okay.
It's fine.
He's red rank.
He's... It's fine!
He's red rank!
Just...
The fact that he lost one round to me when I had three days of Tekken.
That's the sad part.
I need to like... Okay.
There's like this move that I can never get correct.
Like the kick.
Like the low kick right here.
Please!
The one-two kick!
Why can't I do it?
Please!
Oh, there you go.
This move.
I keep fucking it up.
I keep fucking it up!
The two!
Please!
Why can't you do this kick?
There you go.
That's why.
And then it's supposed to be like this.
And then...
Not that.
It's the timing.
I'm not good at timing apparently.
Exactly.
These people...
Okay, the thing is.
Have much longer Tekken hours and days of doing combos than me.
And I'm coming in with three days here.
Any round I take...
Is like a win for me.
With the amount of Tekken experience I have.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
Okay, what she expect?
Can you tell this person is a...
Lazy against King's law?
There you go.
Because I know you like to duck.
So...
Oh god.
Wi-Fi warriors.
Is she on Wi-Fi or am I on Wi-Fi?
Is it my PC?
We'll find... We'll figure it out here.
Yay!
What the fuck?
Sometimes I don't do the jump...
The...
The low punch.
No, not low punch.
The low kick.
Oh, it's because my fingers...
Were on the wrong area.
Please.
Thank you.
That's all I care.
Please.
Please stop.
Stop.
Doki.
Same.
Doki, please.
I know.
I...
I like tell that to myself every day.
Please!
Oh my god!
I got a perfect the one time my combos actually work.
The one time my fingers actually work for me.
Okay, do you think she's gonna duck?
Okay, she's just gonna beat me up.
Doki, please.
Okay.
Guys.
Look.
We know my place.
Guys.
You think I can improve like...
Improve 10 speeds in the next 3 days?
We'll find out.
Okay, let's play against...
I don't care.
People are like...
People keep telling me to discriminate against the WiFi players.
And reject all WiFi players.
But I was like, I really don't care.
I don't care.
Wait, do we join?
Wait, which stage are we?
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Nobody said anything!
How was I supposed to know where...
Oh, shit.
I'm not focused.
I was looking at my Discord.
Alright.
I'm not focused.
I was looking at my Discord.
Oh, my God.
He actually ducks.
Who would have thought?
Coach, I got a question for you.
Yeah, what's up, bro?
You in a match right now?
Yeah.
Let me know when you're out.
I want your insight on something real quick.
Please.
I'm a believer.
I think...
You came in thinking that I'm gonna go far.
It's nice that somebody believes in me, you know?
Wait, you actually blocked Lowe's?
Bro, what the fuck?
What's wrong with you?
You think you can block this?
No.
This is literally my one move.
If all else fails...
If all else fails, I have that one move.
Now imagine losing a fucking Ranna off of me.
What are you gonna do?
Do I do this?
Hey.
Do I do this again?
Alright, no.
He fucking learned.
Okay.
But what if I do it again?
He does not learn.
I told you.
That's like the only thing I know how to do.
Oh god.
Okay.
You think he's gonna learn again?
Nope.
Alright, let's try again.
You think he learned?
Oh, he did.
He learned.
Cause he's trying to get closer now.
He's trying...
He's not giving me space anymore.
Bro.
There's no way she would do it again, right?
But there was a way.
You think he learned?
No.
You think he learned, guys?
He doesn't learn.
I told you.
That's like literally the only thing I know.
Well, not the only thing.
But one of the things that I consistently do.
Is just like...
You guys...
You think he finally learned?
Guys, I don't think he learned.
That's so sad.
That's the thing is I can't do that for real on people though.
Cause everybody else trained for like 20 plus hours.
Not the one and done.
Yeah, I do that to everybody.
I do that to all the players.
They never do.
Yeah, it's a bit toxic.
I didn't realize that was so toxic.
I was just like... I was just like... Bro, I'm Clearly you can beat the shit out of me.
I'm not gonna fucking give you another game.
Like...
I'm just trying to fucking have fun.
Okay, I did not mean to jump there.
That was an accident.
Guys, I think this guy will learn though.
This guy might learn.
Guys... whoa!
You think this guy will learn though?
We'll figure it out.
There we go.
Okay, give me space.
Give me space so I can see if you learn.
Oh, he does!
See, why can't that other guy do it?
Because he... because you're not yellow.
Has the tourney ended?
No, we're just waiting for the next round to start.
He didn't need to learn.
Because like he... he actually is a good... good enough...
Okay, I know some people are like, bro, he's bronze.
He's... that's good enough for me.
That's a good...
Good rank for me... with me as a player.
That's a lot.
Yeah, this guy... see, this guy knows!
Like, why can't the other guy do that?
I don't know why I kept trying to do it.
I was just like, maybe it'll be different, you know?
Okay, well this is scary.
This guy is...
It was just like...
That guy's first time playing King.
Bro, he's yellow rank.
There's no way that that guy was the first time he played.
Oh god, he's faster.
He's so much faster.
No!
Oh my god, I'm...
Goodbye.
Oh...
Oh, goodbye!
It was his first King.
As long as you have time to hit up your coach.
It sucks, because like...
Oh my gosh.
Okay, so like, Hey, Bronpro and I were talking, like, I think like, the day before yesterday, and then we were...
Because like, I was like, what the fuck?
Because like, it was supposed to be Connor, right?
Connor was supposed to be in my seed, and then Connor got replaced by another player that's played Tekken before.
I was like, wait, what the fuck?
Like...
HAHAHAHAHA.
Like, she plays a lot of Tekken.
And I was like, wait a minute.
Cjop told me this is for newbies only.
What the...
What am I doing here?
I was just like...
I'm just...
I'm just like...
Oh my god, I'm gonna get absolutely destroyed.
Oh hey, that...
This king knows what he's doing.
Bro, he like...
He's like, stars.
Because he knows I want to do that thing.
That only I can do.
Please.
Yeah, I'm like...
The only other...
Yeah, but like, Gumi, when she gets into a game, she plays a lot of hours of that game.
And then I, unfortunately...
Okay, I should actually play this game though.
Okay.
Sorry, I was having a conversation, fellow king player.
I have to stream.
Sorry.
I think it was alright.
Gumi's been fucking grinding.
We just talked about you guys behind your backs and that's about it.
He's actually been grinding.
I had other obligations.
You had a question or something before I got pulled into that?
Oh, yeah.
Let's say...
Hold on.
Let's say I want to get...
Actually, I'm going to run so I can do it.
Oh my god.
Does this...
Oh my...
Sometimes my fucking down doesn't register and that makes me sad.
Oh, wait.
You should block that.
You're a king player.
You block this?
Oh, he does.
Let's say...
I want to go full gen Shen.
That's so many of the...
This is the only week I was free.
I was fully free.
Everyone tried it so much.
Oh, Jesus.
Alright, never mind.
Holy shit.
Oh, it's because I'm doing monitor capture.
That's probably what it is.
Maybe.
Do you want to see?
Do you want to try?
Hold on.
My only hours to grind Tekken was like...
It starts at like around 8 to 10.
Like around 8 to 10 p.m.
is when I start grinding Tekken.
The last three days.
The first day.
I grinded Tekken.
The first day I had a lot of time because it was like right after announcing WrestleTuber.
So I went straight into it.
And then I...
And then I started and then I grinded I think like the day after.
And then you dash into the down forward.
My day starts for grinding because I have to do my other obligations first.
My other work hours stuff first.
And then I start at like 8 or 10 p.m.
That's when I start.
Then everybody else starts way earlier.
72?
You can...
Okay, see how much it is if you just back three into the Jaguar Bomb.
But like for now, now I have a lot of time.
Now I have a lot of time.
But like everybody is now like 20 hours.
I heard like SK has like nine hours.
I heard like SK has like 90 hours plus when I started.
I don't care about optimizing it.
Yeah.
Let's just pause.
No, I meant like...
No, I didn't mean like 8 to 10.
I mean I start at either 8 o'clock or 10 p.m.
But then I would play until 4 in the morning.
I would play until 4 in the morning.
I would start at like 8, 7.
Or 7 to 10 p.m.
And then I'd grind until 4 a.m.
But then like by the time I started grinding, SK had fucking 90 hours.
And like I think she...
I think she has like like a 130 plus hours now.
And now here I am.
I never use this move.
And I was looking at the intel report.
You could also do 1 plus 2 is 3 after watching them.
I was looking at the intel report and all the other newbies were like close to Red rank already.
were like close to Red rank already.
I was like what the fuck.
And some newbies have had tanking experience before.
I'm like, what am I doing here?
What am I doing here?
I thought newbies meant as a newbie newbie.
Oh, you can try that as well.
I went in thinking newbie meant actually newbie.
So what's this on the damage?
But newbies were not... I didn't realize newbies have not meant newbie anymore.
I can't believe it.
Got it.
I'm trying.
You think she knows how to... no, she doesn't give me space for this.
I got sent to the wuzz.
I did.
Maybe I can fit in one match.
I got sent to the fucking gulags.
Oh my god, I don't get the one-on-one.
Oh wait, that was not what I wanted to do.
In two days, I'll just scream way earlier.
Yeah, like the average was much higher.
But I'm having fun.
I'm having fun though.
Learning Tekken for...
Wait, why am I playing as a red?
Every single round went game five by the way.
So everything is like dead even right now.
Alright, it's fine.
She's red.
I'm having fun though.
But it's like... I'm just like what the fuck am I doing here?
You know, if you guys do end up burying me this time around, I'm totally cool with that.
Because I did a lot of work last time.
You only played a couple sets.
And that's how I'm feeling.
But I'm still trying, right?
It's a quick match.
I'm trying.
That man went five.
I'm 0, bro.
I mean...
You lose.
I only lost to one person.
What did you do?
You know, you beat one guy, right?
The tiebreaker, dude.
It's all mental.
I mean, you won one set though, you know?
So...
Damn, he ain't fucking called out.
I don't know.
When is our next round starting?
It started.
So you can end it.
I'm gonna try to enter the...
Oh, nice.
Yeah, if you go up to...
What is it?
Stage one.
All right, stage one.
And then you gotta copy paste.
Let's see.
I learned how to do it for real this time.
All right.
Time to get my ass kicked.
Let's go.
10 hour Doki versus 110 hour SK.
Let's get it.
Oh, okay.
I was telling them about the SK thing.
Yeah.
10 hour session.
I'm gonna do it.
Yeah, I'm not catching up to SK.
There's not enough hours in the day for me to catch up.
Wait, no.
You can radio up, can't you?
Okay, yeah.
They said you guys are good to go.
Maybe I can ask SK to give me like one free hit.
DM her.
DM her right now.
Can I have one free hit?
Yeah, just so Doki knows.
Okay, you can radio up right now.
I only have 10 hours.
Slime.
You gotta do the little toggle state thingy.
And the FDC guy has to do it too.
There you go.
Yay.
Time to 3-0 SK.
SK, please.
Let's get it.
Just let me have one hit.
That's all I got.
I want it.
No, we're getting several hits.
Okay.
True, true, true.
True.
I'm gonna, like, dream of that too.
We will land many moves.
A combo even.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
A com- okay, maybe you're asking a bit too much.
A combo actually.
Whoa!
A combo.
We hit a 1-1.
I don't think I've seen that before.
That's what I'm saying.
Okay.
Alright.
That's right.
I gotta get into the mental of winning of one hit in the combo.
And you can just also just use it as a learning experience too.
That's true.
It's only round robin one.
I'm gonna give them like a false sense of security so when the finals hit...
Are you still in the game Doki?
Yeah.
I'm like loading up.
We're in now.
I think we all got dropped from the special.
Wait.
What?
Oh thank god.
Okay.
Well I pulled up SK stream.
I'm still on SK stream.
Guys I got a hit!
Guys!
You wouldn't believe it.
I got three hits!
Oh my god!
What?
Wait.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Why did you do that?
Why did you guys drop when I got hit?
I couldn't KO!
What?
Alright.
Now it's all downhill.
No!
Guys I can't believe it!
We can't believe the one time you guys got locked out.
Bro.
Hell.
Why am I so unlucky?
Let's get it!
That's shit!
Oh no.
Okay.
That's alright.
I think SK was maybe toying with me for real.
Okay.
Goodbye.
You do more grabs than I do.
You're popping shit I haven't seen.
Oh my god.
I don't even know what I'm doing.
That JK I know what I'm doing.
That's right.
It's all about the fun.
I got my one hit.
Just keep grabbing.
I think you win if you just grab like a madman.
That's true.
Oh my god.
You're right.
Okay.
They learned.
Yeah.
They learned the down on the controller.
Wait.
What the fuck?
I think now is when we use the RDC.
RDC technique.
You can do it.
I bet it'll work.
True.
Oh no.
Now I'm in a long ass combo.
How is she so fast?
Nice.
Okay.
No.
I'm not fast enough.
I think she'll do a one plus two after.
Why is she so fast?
Yeah.
Rain is cheap.
Is this why everybody plays her?
Oh.
It's all right.
I got my two rounds.
Now I'm happy.
That was impressive.
You almost had... Lock in.
Lock in and this is actually yours.
Okay.
I believe so hard.
All right.
At least somebody believes in me.
Hey.
I believe.
But do you believe in me in your heart though?
Yes.
Or is it just words?
No.
I believe.
What you just did.
I think if you get your offense off, you're good.
Just run your stuff.
Oh my God.
Please.
Please escape.
I thought you were going gentle on me.
Escape.
Please let me have a move.
Oh, come on.
Nice mix with that shit.
Oh God.
Hey, remember your fight or flight?
Yeah.
We can try that.
Oh, escape like knows I want to escape.
I can't believe she knows King players like to grab.
Yeah.
Who did?
Who?
Honestly, who taught her this?
I know.
It's actually crazy.
100 hours.
It must be like all the King players she fought.
Forbidden knowledge.
Okay.
I thought I was going to land.
Me too.
Oh.
Rain is shooting.
Oh, I'm going to die.
There's a rain.
Rain is cheap.
That's.
Oh my God.
She ducked.
Stop ducking.
It's being taller.
Goodbye.
I had a good one set.
Oh, that's good luck.
Oh.
Nice try.
It's alright.
I had my moment in the beginning.
I grabbed two rounds off a 110 hour SK.
Two rounds?
Not bad.
I think once we just teach you mids, like to counteract the duck, it's easy.
I think once you play 100 more hours...
Yeah, I just need 100 more hours.
I can see that.
100 more hours of game before Friday.
We can make that work.
It's so easy.
Who needs sleep?
It's all about the Tekken.
Hold on, I gotta join back in that lobby.
What do I fucking... No, get me out of here.
Guys, I can't believe...
I can't believe it!
They got spectated on the rounds!
I actually do well!
What is my luck?
I was like, oh thank god they DC'd.
They don't have to watch this.
You played Power Rangers?
Alright.
Oh, I thought it was Raiditz.
Is it Catlin?
Thank fucking god!
Slime has Raiditz, yeah.
Oh, it's... okay, got you.
Wait, really?
I thought... oh wait!
I thought it was... dude, we ran into Raiditz yesterday.
Oh yeah!
We have data!
Oh yeah?
We can tell you some shit.
Yeah, Slime.
Yeah, seriously.
I'm so down.
I did it.
Cause I thought... I thought I was fighting Raiditz.
I fucking did it.
I was ready to go.
Get ready for the next battle!
You got this shit.
Alright.
I do not know Azusena, but we learn on the fly.
I believe.
Good sidestep.
Alright, we're just backing up a lot.
This is grabs.
Oh my... we're doing that until they...
They're probably getting active coaching about it though.
Yeah.
Nice block, Kony!
Oh!
Why am I delayed?
I mean...
Three points!
Yeah, last night with the rank.
Three points.
Distributor.
Ooh!
We're just cleaning up Azusena nation here.
What the fuck was that?
Dude, all the way.
Oh my... that was a good bridge.
Oh!
Oh, I'm like five seconds behind you guys.
Is that a wall coach?
Bro, don't do that, bro.
I think it might be.
I think that might be a wall.
Oh my god, what a combo.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Chat, I'll be able to do that in three days.
Stop breaking ones, bro!
I hope they coach is talking.
It's dress up.
Oh, now it's ones.
Okay, we only break ones.
Okay.
Might just be mashing the one-one move.
That move right there.
Yeah.
Yeah, because it's doing the counter hit sound.
So she's just mashing one.
Oh, such a smart decision from a smart player named Coney.
Oh my god, who is he?
Knee into any other grab that isn't one.
And I mean, you take it easy.
3-0 as well.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's just keep going twos.
Yeah, just do two.
She's literally mashing one.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm like, oh, I'm like, oh, I'm like, oh, I'm like, oh, I'm like, oh, I'm like, I'm like, go from the floor.
Oh, what?
Wait, what quit?
That's fine.
I wanted to change my skin anyway.
It's a mental game.
We're gonna change our skin to the baneskin from last night and see if Raiditz knows.
That's him!
I actually, so Slime, I was holding on to last night, I went to last round with Raiditz and I was like alright, I'll lose, which I'm fine with.
But if I spammed back three...
I think I would have beat him.
Because like, he's just mashing, so I don't know how good Bear's power crushes are.
It's pretty good.
Don't like spam it obviously, but like, hold it.
You know what I mean?
It's acceptable, yeah yeah.
Alright, we go B.
He does a three hit over and over.
It's like a kick, then a punch, and then another punch.
It's like back four, two, one.
Oh, never mind.
I am playing Raid.
It's on a different team.
Oh, never mind.
Alright, well then I'm out.
Oh, okay okay.
It's just confusing.
Alright, never mind.
Avoid everything.
Crashing this boat.
He's realizing.
With no survivors!
Fight!
Oh my, wait, she changed her outfit too!
Put me down!
Yeah, every time.
She doesn't know she's minus.
Ooh, love that.
Oh, nice.
Round two.
Fight!
Remember that.
Yes, I know.
Overshore.
Yeah.
Yup.
This will not work in two days.
True.
One, two, one.
Yeah, but then we go level two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
But level two is so fake though.
And then you go to brand destroyer.
Then you go level three!
Then you go brand destroyer!
Then we go back to level one.
We start doing it again.
That's true, yeah.
NL was right, man.
What a dog.
That was all great.
Mm, good low.
She keeps going high there.
Okay.
I'm just gonna keep popping.
I mean, like, fuck, just lock it in, you know?
Like, oh my god.
Just give me my points.
Dude!
If I did the shoulder, I'd win that.
Fuck.
When she hits you with a running three, two, just get up and hold back.
We'll probably do another one.
Okay.
Round four.
Fight.
Shoulder.
Shoulder is too hard.
Maybe one day.
Okay.
Listen, next time.
You know, tomorrow, you're literally gonna be five hours of running.
I was gonna say, I'm doing shoulder drills tomorrow.
Seriously.
Like, I just, if I do that, I'm good.
Like, just imagine what if you lost because you didn't hit that confirm.
And that will motivate you.
I know.
You're gonna be like, oh, I'm gonna do this.
Okay.
You'll never ever ever.
Ooh.
Good shit.
Let's go .
Fucking solid.
Tony wins.
Yeah.
Fucking easy.
Tony wins.
Good shit.
Okay.
Get in there, Boo Boo Bear.
Nice.
Who are you fighting against?
Oh, this guy.
The thing-Wang.
Way.
You just beat a Tekken King, Kishin, Kishin Cousins, and shit.
I do, I will say, I've played this character very little.
I'll be Kishin your mom.
That's what I'm saying bro.
Not my mom.
That's what I DM'd to all these guys.
Alright, we can go in ready?
Run it.
Uhh...
Let's go.
Go log brother.
You know...
Guys, do you guys believe in me?
That I'll learn a lot more Tekken moves in two days?
Do you guys believe?
In two days, I'm gonna improve so much.
I swear.
Why does this bear have a rose?
He's just deli- Wait.
What?
I can feel it.
Okay.
He knows.
He knows the G-Cluster.
He analyzed your playstyle.
Oh wow.
Oh?
Just never let him get up.
Damn it.
After you get hit by the splits, just hold back.
He's 2+.
Okay.
Tio.
What the fuck?
I don't know what he does.
Definitely matchup gap.
Thanks, Hard.
That's not bad.
Wow.
Nice parry.
Oh.
Can I smash?
Nice.
Thanks,
guys.
Thank you.
Thanks.
I'm gonna push.
Oh, this is the first level.
See, this is the first level.
I'm gonna take a side attack along with this first one.
So, this is the first level.
This is the first one.
Nice.
Come
on, all of us.
We can really play like this.
Okay.
Let's go.
Guess what bro?
I dress up like... I dress up with a fucking... a mustache and a revolver.
I'm supposed to come up!
What a break.
Nice!
I think I got him.
I got him.
Yeah, no!
Dude, I'm gonna lose my mind.
That was so close.
I hate this fucking character.
I'll try to go for the ring.
He's smart.
He could have a better move up off that.
What the fuck is that?
That's to stop you from mashing.
Even though what he did was unsafe.
So he's confused too.
What a comeback!
Nice, dude, he's good.
See, he's showing all his cards now.
We know how he plays now.
Get the fuck up!
Why can't I fucking get up, dude?
I was blocking low too, I did a long time.
Yeah, I saw it.
You knew.
What a miserable character to play against.
Yeah, that was horrific.
There's just nothing...
That's a good-ass player though.
He's just a good player.
Yeah, he knows the matchup.
Yeah, it's just a matchup we'll work on.
That's all.
Yeah, we'll go over that whole matchup, dude.
Now you know his playstyle.
You're right though, that did look miserable.
Especially for Bear in particular.
Like, I don't know when he's gonna... I just don't.
Dude, this guy's playing Eddy.
I know for a fact he's playing Eddy.
Hold on, I gotta get out of here.
Not this old ass, this 60 year old man!
What a f- come on, that man!
Okay, we just wanted Brawl Pro to be able to have a match as well.
Put him in a home!
Alright, I'm gonna try.
Here we go.
If I see some like, some obvious stuff, then I will let you know.
I don't wanna interrupt your game though.
Unless it's obvious.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, you just do whatever you need to.
Whatever you feel like is like... he obviously is not picking up on this.
I fucking told you!
What the fuck did I say?
Zafina my ass.
Were you prepped for Zafina?
No, I'm not prepped for either character.
He's about to play his theme song.
Oh my god.
Fuck, I didn't get his strike.
You don't need prep, look at you!
Cyborg Eddy is so funny.
He's like trying.
What a punish, dude.
Cyborg Eddy would be like a Metal Gear boss, right?
Like...
Dancing cat, like...
That's the name.
Fight!
It's the game!
Aquara!
Brawl!
Yeah!
Suck it!
Okay, that's fair.
I thought you said I get that forward too there!
You can.
I tried.
It feels kinda laggy and I've never complained about lag before, hasn't it?
Secretly on Wi-Fi?
The foul wind of the snout.
That's what Doki was trying to do.
He had the wired connection going to a wireless router.
He just unplugged the ethernet cable.
Is it Apple?
After the dive?
Where he tries to take his plus eight?
Where I can down forward too?
After down forward, it's just a fake out move.
I'll show you.
When he does it, I'll mention it.
Backslash.
Oh.
Why is it laggy?
I don't know.
Maybe it's because he's on console.
I swear, dude.
Okay.
It's clean.
He doesn't feel like shit though.
Oh yeah, it's airborne shit.
Oh, nice!
Nice aggression, man.
That.
I need to lav it.
Why is it so laggy?
Is it like it's slow-mo for you guys?
Yeah, it is.
Yeah, it is a little.
Yeah.
All right, lock in.
Lock in.
Two.
Three.
And I'm gonna do that.
Yeah, that's.
It is, yeah.
That's strange.
Bro bursted out the lag switch.
It feels chunky.
I don't like it.
It's the one with the Ethernet cable.
Lips and eyes don't go again.
Nice.
Okay.
Launch!
Oh nice!
The combo makes me so anxious because it looks like...
Oh my...
I did not mean to...
His throw breaks are pretty weak though.
Good shit.
Job spot Nick.
I'm okay with this.
You do kinda deserve it.
Are you still okay with it?
Are you still okay?
What?
Nice, nice, nice.
Why did that track?
It tracked.
It's a full 360.
Bro, thank you morgon.
Nice.
Yeah!
Did this controller DC?
I don't know.
This is such a weird fucking game.
It did.
I'm taking it.
Take it, take it!
There's no fair fight attacking!
Oh wait, no!
He's on...
No!
He plugged it back in!
He's playing Clash of...
He plugged in the mouse and keyboard!
It's on a different controller.
He's on a different... I'm playing!
I was playing on his Alexa!
It's on his Switch now!
Yep.
Boom!
Yeah, that's definitely Switch gameplay there.
It's like chunky, dude.
He's the strongest!
So after he does the dive...
I don't fucking... whatever.
You know what?
I'm down back one.
Fight!
Oh launch!
Oh!
That move.
That low.
That.
Fuck!
It's hard to tell, bro.
Yeah.
I'm sorry!
Nice!
Nice grab.
That was good.
Bro's got kicks.
There's probably one more.
You're cra... what?
That was a crazy move to start with.
Yeah.
Doki knows too.
Yeah!
If I knew that he'd end it's bad!
Just watch the sweep.
Yeah, he's sweeping like crazy, dude.
Just sit and wait.
Cash out.
I hate it.
Fight!
Ooh.
Why the fuck?
I don't get it.
You're serious, Gary.
I don't know...
What the fuck?
I don't know, Eddie.
I don't know.
Dude, he's spinning around!
I don't know, Eddie.
I literally don't know, Eddie.
Fucking let it rip!
He should have a dizzy meter.
Dude, I've never seen this before.
He should have a dizzy meter and if it fills up, he vomits.
Somebody stop this man.
This shit...
nobody can do this.
Nobody can do this for real, Eddie.
No, human alive.
What a launch.
Dizzy meter?
Bro, that's incredible.
Dizzy meter.
Just bring back all the stamina bar.
If it fills, he has a 360 frame bomb.
He's vomiting animation.
Bring back the stamina bar at this point as well.
Stamina bar!
Eddie's tired!
He's tired!
He needs some rest.
He breathes like Mario when he has red health.
He's like, woohoo!
I've been lied to by my coach.
Dude, what the fuck?
You guys are the fuck?
Nah, I've been lied to.
I've been lied to.
See, right?
It's our coach's fault.
You're dead.
I'm dead.
I'm not dead.
Wow.
He's been paid off by Big Feedy X.
Quick, unplug his controller.
What's the most damage possible from the Rage Art?
No, he was airborne.
Oh, Jesus.
Now you still see how much he does.
Oh!
Okay.
That's good.
What?
Oh!
Watch the Rage Art.
No!
Let's fuck this!
Oh, baby!
Let's go!
Oh my god!
The coming!
He's the strongest!
What the fuck I'm talking about?
Let's fucking go!
If you joined the sling, you would defeat everyone?
You're fucking right!
Whoa!
What?
He didn't need a prep for him.
Also, GG.
That was really fun.
Jesus with a Neuralink.
Amazing.
That's right.
He didn't even need to fucking prepare.
Whew.
What almost left the...
We're lapping the Eddie matchup, bro.
That was me fighting without any Eddie knowledge.
Who is this?
Dude, I think if you just block low a lot...
Wait, guys.
Who is this guy?
Who is this?
I think that's...
Is that not...
I thought this was FDX's team.
That's FDX, the Tekken King Reina.
Don't you know?
He's working on it.
He's working on the Reina.
Is he bringing the Reina or is he fucking with you?
This guy beat Justin Wong, so I'm gonna need you to lock in.
He's good.
There's a lot of people in our lobby.
No, that's him.
Wait, who is the Reina?
Just lost in the wrong lobby.
Who the fuck was that guy?
Wait, did somebody leave the coders?
There's a lot of people joining in.
That's like the ghost of Marvel.
You gotta play me.
Yeah, dude.
Oh my god.
I love that guy.
That's one of the...
That's one of my top five FGC clips all time.
That's one of the top five FGC clips all time.
Nobody stopped him.
He got all the way up to Chris G.
It's so funny.
All the way up to him.
Because so many people watch that and they're like, how did nobody stop him?
And people who are like in eSports production are like, oh, I get it.
Like, yeah, right.
FD is malding?
Why are there so many people in the lobby?
Who leaked it?
I would mald it.
V said that.
V said he didn't make a public one.
So...
I mean, he didn't make a private lobby.
I think people just like fouled our lobby.
We got all these fuckers.
When I fucked it up, at least I made it private.
You know what I mean?
True.
I was like, I don't...
These are too many names.
I think
he's asleep for two hours.
Oh.
This is a concussion for sure.
This actually damages him into the next round.
He's sleeping.
It's true.
Ouch.
Oh.
What?
I didn't know that low kick was lit.
That's crazy.
What?
I mean, this character won evo so it's not your fault.
You're just playing off meta, you know?
Yeah.
Look at this.
We're just giving her a free round, right?
Oh my god, I know how to do that move!
That's a fucking awesome rage art.
Beat him!
That's mental.
You're welcome Brawl Pro.
SpeedyDex is like, I can't believe you did that.
I just can't believe you did that.
He's raging!
Nice.
Don't worry, I'll be able to do that too.
Bounce... and...
drop.
Oh no.
Oh!
Oh my god!
What are you looking at?
There's no pain over there!
That was so sick.
That was crazy.
That's genuinely the closest thing to the mango that you can get in this game.
The literal perfect optimal back turn punish.
That's legacy as fuck.
Oh!
Uh oh.
Yeah bro is laying down.
Damn.
That's a lot.
Okay.
Counter hit giant swing dealer.
Does he no detect?
I don't think so.
Imagine.
It's a god of destruction thing.
It's like, are you detecting?
Are you seeing?
Oh my god.
Break the stage so I can do that move you've been yelling at me to do.
Good grab.
Ain't no way he's not breaking ones.
Nina has that move.
Nice!
Nina, our friend.
Love that.
No way!
Let's hit one B!
He's scared of the 1 plus 2 though.
Oh my goodness!
Oh!
Did you hear the chump on that?
Yeah.
Keep doing it.
She doesn't learn.
Boom boom.
Spin around.
Look at the ball coach.
Bounce coach!
Break the stage!
Oh hell no!
What the fuck!
It's still going.
It's still fucking going.
Oh stop.
How dare you.
Oh wow.
I hate that game.
No revenge.
Damn.
Oh those are faked.
That's launch bro.
Oh!
Nice.
Send him in a one touch.
Is that fully KO?
No.
It scales down a lot.
Cause she's in the air right?
It's one mix.
It just doesn't scale well during combos.
Huge break.
Time for a little gaming.
Wait it out.
No don't wait it out.
Damn it.
No!
Very close.
Now you're in my house.
Ping should be able to run backwards.
I got you for three minutes.
Three minutes.
Bro pro is ready.
Bro pro
is ready.
Nice.
What a call.
Good shit.
Oh damn it.
She ducked it.
She's dead.
Nice!
Never rage arts.
Oh nice.
Oh my god.
Hey what if this is guaranteed?
What if this is guaranteed?
Oh.
What if they call them freaky king?
Freaky king.
What if they call it freaky A?
He ducked.
He actually ducked.
It's fine.
He's playing with his food.
Break man.
Yeah!
He was gaming.
Let's go!
That was fucking fun to watch.
Let's go coach.
Good shit.
I'll be able to do that in three days guys.
Hell yeah.
Dude that one round where you guys just 80%ed each other back and forth was...
That was sick.
Non stop combos forever.
Good shit dude.
That was the hard team by the way.
They won 4-1.
And now we beat them what 3-2 I think?
That was the hardest team in the whole tournament.
I'm so happy man.
I lost the last coach match so I'm glad I won this one.
Had to bring it back for the team.
Okay.
That was fun as well.
Good set.
That was fun yeah.
I'll remember the time I took two rounds off SK forever.
Hehehe.
Man.
Yeah this is fun.
I missed the first AJM slam.
You like that shit?
It's stressful but it's fun man.
We just like...
We gotta wait for the next stage now.
Back to quick play.
Yeah actually let me pop in a ring.
Cause we got a while.
Alright.
Alright guys.
It's back to quick play.
Maybe this time.
Guys I swear.
I will land one combo.
Today.
Hahaha.
That's not on the bot.
I swear to god.
No.
Oh wait I got the map I wanted.
I learned so much.
What do you mean?
Look.
Okay watch this.
Okay.
Boom.
Now let's see if I can do that on a real person.
Hahaha.
Yo are we right into it?
We're waiting.
I think we're still waiting.
Look.
I'll be able to do that on a real person soon.
Hahaha.
I gotta fight my roommate Josh.
Are you guys gonna offline it or no?
No we should play online.
Cause we can both get left.
And uh.
It's probably less complicated to like.
Perspectate.
Wait who the fuck rank is this person?
Round 1.
Fight.
Oh 12.
Woah.
Sorry bro.
Oh god please.
Please.
Oh god.
I don't know your moves.
Hahaha.
Wait do I get that?
Oh I do.
I get that.
Nooo.
Goodbye.
Hahaha.
Is that your?
Who's your?
How many more rounds?
I think we have.
I think we're fighting.
Fighting every team.
And there's 6 teams in total.
So uh.
Watch this.
Hahaha.
This is literally my favorite move.
Oh god.
Please.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'll never do that again.
JK.
I'm not sorry.
Do not duck!
Watch this.
Hahaha.
That's literally the only thing I know how to do.
JK.
I also know.
Oh wait.
I know how to do this.
But do you think she learned?
No.
They never learn.
That's why I like doing it.
Because they don't learn.
There you go.
They never learn.
Hahaha.
Nope.
Okay.
I messed that up though.
They never expect it.
Why don't they?
I don't understand.
They should expect it.
Like.
It's such a good move.
Oh.
Alright.
Bye.
Hahaha.
See.
They never learn.
Oh wait.
She did the thing to me.
Yay!
I beat a vanquisher.
Yippee!
I don't get anything because it was quick play.
Hahaha.
Yippee!
This is a winning I like to see.
Goodbye.
I'm a one and done person.
Hahaha.
I'm pressing buttons.
One button.
One day I'll be able to do this in game.
One day!
Hehe.
Don't worry.
By the time the second round hit.
Round robin two hits.
I'll be able to do that in game.
One and done.
Hahaha.
This evil monkey.
She will live without defeat forever.
I bet you that person has been practicing Tekken for like fucking weeks and I rolled up the screen.
I ruined her day.
I hope this person knows I'm streaming and finds out I've only been playing Tekken for like for like three days.
That's all I want.
Can she dodge this?
No.
Oh!
She can!
But can she dodge this?
Oh!
Hahaha.
Okay I should stop fucking around.
Please let me up.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I was fucking her.
Hahaha.
They never expected twice.
Okay.
But does she expect again?
Oh wait she did.
Okay but do you think she'll expect it again?
Oh she just swings yes.
Okay I should stop trolling now.
For real.
Okay for real this time.
Hahaha.
Do not move Doki.
Oh.
Oh man.
I wanna do this move that my coach keeps telling me to do but I can never pull it off in a real fucking game.
Cause it's so difficult.
Please.
I'm trying.
I really wanna do that move that my coach wanted me to do.
Hahaha.
Please.
I can block.
It's just that like I get impatient.
Alright.
Watch me block.
Okay you guys think I can't block?
Watch this.
Wait this person has 13 wins in a row.
This guy is actually a fucking bullying noob.
See!
Look at that!
I told you.
I told you I knew how to block.
Nobody believes me ever.
Hahaha.
Watch this.
See!
I told you I can block moves.
Oh.
Do I hit these?
Yeah I do.
I told you!
Do not in the actual.
Look this is not the tournament.
This is just a round robin.
Hahaha.
There's love bow.
There's jump.
Yo.
Lobby is up.
Okay.
I'm gonna lose real fast.
Yeah me too.
I'll be in in one second.
Oh my god.
Me too.
But I can't unmute myself.
Ah!
Look chat last.
It's okay.
I'm purposely losing.
I muted the wrong thing.
I'm sad now.
Guys.
I'm purposely losing guys.
Guys you don't understand.
He just ducks and launches me?
No way.
Can I keep doing this?
That sucks.
And I'm gonna leave and he's gonna be furious.
I feel really bad.
Okay.
This guy's good and I'm just one and done-ing him after I win.
He did promo off me.
Okay.
Please I need to lose.
Dude I'm sorry.
Thank god.
Okay.
I fought a drag who was very good and cleaned me up first round.
And then I beat him second game and I left.
Because we had to get in his lobby.
Oh I feel bad.
Okay.
Alright.
Thank god.
Okay.
If that guy comes in here I'm gonna apologize.
Alright.
Now to join.
Where the fuck is it?
Oh there you go.
Oh my god.
Which guy?
He is Sam!
Oh fuck.
Okay.
He slapped me first round.
And second round I beat him and I had to leave.
So I just got my win and then left.
So he thinks you ran.
He thinks you ran.
Yeah.
He thinks I'm bad.
I feel bad bro.
My bad.
Oh there's a passcode.
Excellent leak?
Listen.
Nobody's coming in here right?
We're good.
If that guy comes in here his name was Legday Germ I think.
Hey if you're watching.
Legday Germ.
Hahaha.
Maybe his Twitch won't be the same as his...
Steam name.
Oh god.
Dough King versus...
Hahaha.
I believe.
I'm going in there with confidence.
And you saw Kony's match and my match.
Yeah I absorbed that.
I absorbed all of that.
Just do the same shit.
Exactly.
Maybe you guys should change your name to Dough King as well.
Hahaha.
Free publicity.
Okay I see.
Alright here we go.
Mission survive.
What the fuck?
King.
No.
Why?
No I forgot to put my costume on.
Oh it's okay.
Hahaha.
That's probably a big deal for like YouTubers right now.
No.
I'm wearing my costume.
And I'm default Dan.
Default Dan?
Okay.
Restart.
Alright.
Freaking ESAM and SK.
The ES people man.
With so many hours on the game.
ES.
Spanish.
Spanish folks.
Oh god.
Please let me get up.
I hate martial arts.
Please.
I'm sorry I hit you.
Just let me get up.
Hahaha.
Cook this man.
RKO his ass.
Martial law hates rich people.
King is not rich man.
Oh god.
He's pro wrestler.
Can I get up in time?
No.
Hahaha.
This kill is on.
No.
Wow.
Wait I'm alive.
Okay.
Hahaha.
It was nice being alive for a second.
Wait.
I'm lost.
Are we stage 2?
Wait what?
Yeah we are.
We started the game.
Yeah Ducky is in her match.
Yeah I'm in my match right now.
And martial law is unfortunately cooking.
Oh my god.
Yeah he is definitely cooking.
Okay.
He's like 3 ranks above me.
Uh I think it's more than 3.
Hahaha.
It's okay I can catch up.
Oh.
That's right.
I told you I can catch up.
Hahaha.
I can get to red rank in less hours.
I believe.
Actually we'll do that.
You know what?
Yeah you know what?
I'm alive.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm giving them a false sense of security in round robin 1.
And I'm gonna roll up in red rank in round robin 2.
Wait I'm alive.
He's gonna slide again.
Hahaha.
We gotta download from the first round.
Ducky we gotta download from the first round.
Like Slime is doing.
We gotta do that.
Hahaha.
That's it.
In the second set.
I'll remember that.
It's cause I'm not in my costume.
I'm getting distracted.
Yeah it's costume debuff.
I mean it's a real thing.
His boots are so shiny.
I just noticed.
Oh my god.
This nerd Ethan.
Hahahaha.
8000 hours.
Some of us have lives.
Yeah.
Some of us have other stuff to do.
But it's okay.
I've delayed that.
I guess if this video game is like so important for you.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Wow you must really wanna go to Evo.
Wow.
I can pay for my own ticket.
Hahaha.
Yeah all of us already won a trip.
Ducky is a multi billionaire.
Fuck yes.
I don't know what I'm doing anymore.
Hahaha.
No don't make me laugh.
Oh my god.
Shmeesh man.
Please.
Please my coach made me laugh.
Hahaha.
Did that bounce?
Let's go.
Nobody is laughing over there.
Hahaha.
We're not having any fun.
Let's be real here.
What are the real stakes?
We got a trip to Evo.
Ducky, billionaire, multi millionaire.
Yeah I'm having fun.
We got three content creators.
Exactly.
This is all about making content.
Oh that was clean though.
Oh shit I got it.
Content let's go.
The only person that probably couldn't afford it was BrawlPro.
Hahaha.
Yeah.
What the fuck.
Shut up.
Let's go.
I got a round.
I got a round off of red.
Oh shit.
That was my bad.
Ooosh.
Oops.
My hands always go onto the wrong position sometimes.
Nice call out.
Yes.
See I'm learning.
I had a feeling because he kept ducking.
He's a duck lord.
Yeah.
See I knew I could learn.
Break his arm.
Yeah.
He can't afford insurance.
Hahaha.
That's true he is poor.
Wait a minute.
Mix up.
No.
Nice try.
To be honest Noki did you know the mix up there?
Did you know like what to do after the...
Yeah.
Because whenever I do that throw I don't know what to do.
I'm like uh oh.
We're both guessing.
We're both hitting a button on the controller.
Something would work.
Hahaha.
There's a lot.
Whenever King does that.
You're like Clay?
It's crazy.
You'll be molded into a killer.
Look at what a couple of hours I can do.
Imagine what happens if I get like 40 more hours.
You will absolutely make it.
I can.
I believe.
With your belief I believe.
And hey.
You can just buy the ticket.
Hahaha.
You can buy your own fucking liberalist.
I want the mental warfare.
Hahaha.
Imagine losing a round to a yellow.
Broooo.
Someone's coming.
He's stone faced right now.
So they weren't having a good time.
Really?
Josh is dead silent.
And all he cares about is vibes.
Here I go.
I'm locking in.
We're winning like the content wars.
That's what the real Brawl throne is all about.
That's where all the views are at.
We didn't even win last slam.
Did we?
No.
That's true.
That's what everybody talks about.
Yeah, we're coming in with more content.
It's the truth.
I need to get the fuck out of here, my bad.
Oh, you gotta swap out.
Oh shit!
Give me a sec.
Actually, I think it's gonna kick you out.
I thought they were gonna swap me.
They can swap me, like...
automatically.
Mm-hmm.
Round one.
Oh, Raidus.
Ni ha!
That third hit, you can duck it.
Yeah, I remember.
Just gotta get hop kicked after the second.
No!
I tried to back up.
Yeah, that's my fault.
I tried to back up and I tried to do a hop back and then I did that kick.
Round two.
Fight!
Dragunov Moisturize Challenge.
Impossible.
Okay, I'm about to say this guy doesn't know.
I think he knows, guys.
Don't break your win streak!
Funny, after you get hit with that down two, you can challenge it with while standing four.
He's a minus one after that.
The spinny low he's doing, just mash for it.
It's a mix-up, but I don't think he's gonna play that mix-up.
Oh my god, counter hit grabs.
He's mashing, bro.
Bro, he's just like me.
Dude, he's actually just mashing.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's just buttons.
Oh!
Wait, mash him back!
It's just fucking buttons, dude.
Okay.
All right, he loves the low.
Off of a... off of a go.
Yeah, that's that down two that killed you.
Round four.
Dude.
Fight!
Oh my god.
Oh.
He's just like me.
He's just so mashing, man.
Oh my god.
Tried to create space.
Whoa!
Just look at the damage here.
Oh!
God!
I thought he was against the wall.
Bring his arm!
Got it.
There's no way.
Let's go, baby.
Nice job.
He broke it earlier.
Let's go, Ray!
I mean, sorry, Coney.
I got brain rot, sorry.
I got brain rot.
Like, for real.
No disrespect.
So sorry.
That wasn't content?
That was on purpose?
It was for content reasons?
Uh-oh.
It's looking like a Rapskies.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, Ray!
No!
Got it.
All right.
I got it.
Let's go, Coney!
Let's go!
Perfect!
You win!
Ray was like...
He gets run over in the alley kicks.
Yeah, dude.
I was sending it.
Fuck it.
If he can't mash, he doesn't win.
Fight!
That's the wall sending for ya.
Yes, sir.
Yeah, I feel ya.
He always goes low.
I'm gonna grab on that too, yeah.
That's not gonna work on day two, but fuck it.
Yeah.
Well run drills on that one.
Fuck!
Yeah.
No biggie.
Oh, nice!
Does he know how to get up?
I know that move.
Rayjar?
Fuck.
Yeah.
I knew it was low, but I didn't know how to beat it.
Like...
Rayjar would have beat that and follow up.
Okay.
No.
Fight!
Oh, nice!
I won two.
Oh.
Dude, he's just getting that low and since I can't power crush it, I'm not doing anything about it, but he's doing it every time.
He like downloaded you.
There you go.
No, he's coding for it.
He's fine.
Oh, god.
Like, I know what you want, dude.
I know what this fucking guy wants, it's just I have to learn how to beat it.
It's annoying.
Fight!
I gotta stop doing that... oh, never mind.
Why does he keep getting hit with it some half the time?
It makes no sense to me.
And he's probably just guessing the, like a mix-up instead of reaction.
Ugh, yeah, okay.
Oh, okay.
Ah, it's just so much... it's just mashing, dude.
It's just, I don't...
Smash party!
I know.
I know what to do.
I'm just trying to hopkick it.
You got it.
Yeah.
Just try and mash floor instead.
If you can, mentally adapt.
But not a big deal.
Fuck it.
Nice!
That's what we talked about!
Thank you!
Oh no!
I'll be able to do that one day.
Dude, it's the same fucking thing!
Every time!
Oh my god, my controller died?
Okay, it's fine.
Wake up!
That's insane, dude.
Quick!
Plug in the mouse and keys!
It was alley kick.
Oh my god.
I could have alley kicked.
After running through, hopkick.
Nice.
Hopkick.
Nice!
Now I see it.
Good combo!
We're on the wall.
Take him to the other side!
Let's go!
Yes!
Yo!
He might be dead!
One more hit!
Yeah!
Good job.
Just making it close for content.
Just trying to get space.
Stucked.
Nice.
Fuck, man.
We gotta try to stay aggressive.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good grab.
Woo!
Okay, I didn't know what that was, so I didn't do anything about it.
I was like, what the fuck is this?
It's okay.
It's hard to react to.
That's a block.
I will absolutely beat this guy if I just learn this dragon.
Cause like, I keep trying to...
I know it's the low every time.
I just keep trying to hopkick it.
I just need practice.
Yeah.
And then that three hit string too, it keeps counter hitting you.
You could just duck and launch in for it.
I'll be ready.
Also, the low can't kill you.
Like most lows in this game, unless they're giant reactable ones, they're just meant to annoy you and get you to duck.
So like, you're getting really frustrated about the low existing.
It's like, early on, it's okay to eat...
eat it, right?
It's like, keeping composure...
while getting a load is more important.
Also, if you're calling it out that hard, low parry mixup...
Oh, true.
I didn't even think of that.
You know, just slap him in the head about it.
If you want to avoid the whole like, trying to think of while standing for or launch, parry, you know.
I can beat that guy.
I'll beat that guy.
I believe.
I know you can, Coney.
You got this.
You got this, dude.
Grudge match.
Oh, god.
He's probably got...
Dude, he's scary.
I'm ready, but... Bro, look at that rig.
You got this.
I don't mean to disrespect him.
I didn't hide my barrier.
We played a bunch yesterday, so it's like, it's definitely a meta matchup of like... Yeah, there's...
We're gonna see layers when we watch this.
We're gonna see layers.
I thought he was on a list.
Why'd he swap?
Uh, he thought she was lame.
She is.
He's right.
He's 100% right.
Face, real.
Appreciate it.
Get ready for the next battle.
We're in the same house.
See what the ping is.
17.
I'm gonna say 17.
Yup.
Wow.
Fight.
You can launch this while sending one, by the way.
Oh, it's minus 14.
Definitely playing different.
He's not doing orbital.
That's fine.
You're learning now.
Bug it!
So then we do the grab and stuff and running 1 plus 2 makes the difference.
And down back 4, also.
Okay.
Aww.
Nice.
Cool.
Okay.
Nice!
Good shit!
Yeah!
Let's go!
He's gonna start wiggling now because he thinks I'm gonna do that.
Oh my god, the mind games.
Nice breaks.
Oh my god, he just used his first hit.
Come on, Bear Joe!
Yo!
Oh!
Okay, better than nothing.
Let's get it.
That damage.
Nice breaks.
Wow, I mean that's literally layered.
Good shit!
You've played this guy for five years and you just know what he's gonna do.
Oh, he's looking for it.
Yes, sir!
I guess he's over it all.
Oh, there it is.
Finally pulled it out round three.
Round... last round.
That's what destroys me.
Shit.
What a counter hit.
Oh, you're still alive.
Oh, yeah.
He did a lot of damage on the first leap though.
So, I mean, he earns it all back but...
I think he's...
He's not gaining.
He's not gonna run up to me.
He runs up to me.
Oh!
Very close.
A close game, dude.
Oh, that's so close.
Real close, real close.
Well, you are the one that wins.
Oh.
Oh god.
But you...
But you adapted...
You know, so you already know what to do.
Yeah, I think he's...
All right.
That's fine.
I think he's just stronger at adapting.
No, dude.
I feel like...
You, when you adapted, it went way better.
Yeah, you...
He was one...
He was 2-0.
You came back.
Yeah.
He got this, bro.
Has a long hit.
Nice!
He's accuracy, dude.
I don't blame you for keeping this in there.
I thought it worked.
Yeah, I would have done it too.
Yeah, I don't blame you.
That bait.
Nice.
Nice bait, dude.
Good shit!
Oh nice!
Yup, yup!
Oh my...
Yeah, get out of here, pal!
Get out of here.
Leave!
Okay.
He can't do the upgrade.
Not yet, at least.
Nice.
Yo!
What a fucking low blow, dude.
See, you're adapting!
Are you bombing?
Hell yeah.
I'm not trying to do that.
Okay.
What a G-Club!
That's a bear player if you've ever seen one, dude.
One day I'll be just as patient.
Nice!
Oh my god!
I could field all the ears from here.
Oh!
Alright, my game just caught up.
Good shit.
I'm literally behind.
Well done.
By the way, Konyo, you didn't know he won that set?
That's you?
Yup.
Good to know.
Mine's chocolate or export.
Remember that spectating when you spectated Supermatch?
That was so funny.
He went SSJ.
Dragon Ball Z.
Bro, it's blockade.
Oh my god.
He lost half his bar to chip.
Fucking orbital, man.
I'm gonna go for the kill.
Okay, I hit the wall here.
Oh!
Nice!
Nice block.
Nice job.
Nice!
Nice.
He's not adapting anymore!
Dude, I fucking low parried, bro.
I'm so fucking mad.
Oh my god, the input was there.
And there's one grab.
And that was it.
No he's reading Hellsweep.
I'm not gonna do Hellsweep anymore.
Rest again.
Oh god.
It's alright.
I think he's good.
That's the problem.
The problem is if he thinks he's good.
I know Kony says the same sentence as you, bro.
True, true.
There it is.
See, what even was that?
Like, that just hit me.
Unplug his internet right now.
Nice.
Dude, I...
I react pressed.
Duh.
Nice try, bro.
Nice try, nice try.
It's okay.
Game 3.
We got stuff to learn.
It's all good.
He's so fucking not good at this game.
Yeah, I don't know who this guy is, but fuck that man.
That's Tekken.
It's alright.
He showed all his cards.
It's okay.
He knows no more moves.
Yeah, we'll go...
Dude, I can go over this right after the round robin, man.
Yeah, I would love to.
Yeah, it's gotta suck losing to the roommate.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, go to his room right now and unplug.
I heard him pop off, too.
I heard him pop off.
Oh, that's...
I could literally hear him pop off.
Wow, I mean...
What are we doing?
Ugh.
It's just gross.
Make him pay for rent for this month.
Boxbox is hella random, so, you know, we'll see.
I could get out-randomed here.
Genuinely.
Or I could get 7 billion damage for no reason.
And then read a card crush and then it would be okay.
Don't worry about it.
Read a power crush!
I forgot that, like I say this game.
You can't do that!
That is not fair!
This is something you can do, yeah.
Oh my god!
That was crazy.
Just tilt him right now.
Blast him!
Uh, uh, uh.
That was a funnest of crazy.
Mmm.
Oh my god!
Jack is fucking brutal, dude!
Yeah, this is so bad.
Bro, is he even gonna touch him?
Round 3.
He's gonna think about this and...
He's gonna be like, I'm gonna do this in the next round.
He's not getting any amount of money.
Dude, you're gonna be on the ground.
You've gotta be fucking kidding me.
Holy shit!
Alright, well, that was good.
This was like me against Bugs Bugs yesterday.
That's funny you said this, Adam.
That was...
That was really fast.
Yeah, that was like 20 seconds.
Yeah, that was like 20 seconds!
Okay!
I mean, I might still fuck up.
I might still fuck up, you know?
No, you already fucked with his mental.
Bugs Bugs has pretty good mental, though.
From what I've heard.
He's crying.
Check your stream.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is he crying right now?
Oh, I'm mad.
Did you just like, death in his teammates?
Is Chaz telling him he did a great job?
He's in his own echo chamber right now.
Oh, fuck!
Let's go, let's go, let's go!
Oh, drop the sad.
Yup.
Yeah, you just... we're just here to make him feel better.
Yeah, you just...
we're just here to make him feel better.
Oh, that was crazy.
That was nuts.
He's also not wearing the Ness outfit.
This is tournament Asuka.
Oh, no.
This guy's definitely a sinner.
Oh, nice.
Send him to heaven.
Why did you do that?
Why did you do that, bitch?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is this, dude?
Are you guys beefing?
This is exchange.
What?
The James Chan!
Suck my nuts!
He did download you!
This is it!
It's like a Twitter combo.
You can't read it because it's all in Korean.
He's like a jester.
He's like a Japanese Greninja.
Like, this shit looks unbeatable.
Oh my god.
The forbidden moves.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god, he actually downloaded.
That was a good step, yeah.
Cool combo, BoxBox.
Nice 40%.
However...
Good hit.
Ah.
Oh.
We're keeping it close here.
Content, content.
One.
Oh my god.
Oh.
You are greedy, my friend.
Punish her.
It's a sin.
Perfect.
That has to be the quickest round ever.
Greed is a sin.
It is a speedrun.
Put that on speedrun.com right now.
That was fast.
BoxBox of world record.
BoxBox run.
Speedrunning BoxBox.
2-0.
What an insane character.
Holy shit.
That first round was crazy.
That 10 years ahead of time read.
That was crazy.
How does he do it?
Someone said that was like 4 perfect rounds.
Oh my god.
BoxBox any percent.
No glitches.
I'm more of a fan of the glitches category.
That character looks like a fucking glitch, dude.
That shit is illegal.
Like some of that damage is insane.
I mean 4 perfect rounds.
Holy shit.
Get his ass coach.
Slime death and is he going to beat up his roommate?
Fight.
He's like, he's like.
Retire.
I was talking about how you might be beating up Joshman because he's dead.
Oh no no.
I was talking about how to beat him next time.
Oh yeah.
In game.
You gotta fight another freaky Brian.
Look at the movement.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
How is he so powerful?
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna do that combo one day.
He even did the rotation.
What?
What is this?
Nice.
Oh nice.
Oh.
Oh jeez.
Round 3.
Fight.
Yeah!
Oh.
We love hop kicking this household.
Nice.
And boom.
And maybe one.
No maybe a local one.
Eat his ass and go off the wall.
Take him to the wall.
Oh my goodness gracious me.
Eat bro's ass Unk.
Eat his ass.
Oh my god.
Get a spoon.
Scoop it.
Oh man.
He's kinda moving now.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Broke the wall.
He kinda woke up.
Yeah.
Uh oh.
Oh shit.
The comeback?
He said get me outta here.
Let me out.
Time for the other wall.
Uh oh.
One guess.
Guess for game.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
I fucked up.
I almost had it.
I had a missed input.
Nice try.
Oh.
Yeah yeah.
We're just getting close.
False sense of security.
Oh nice.
Nice nice.
That's a freaky Brian.
Nice.
Dude that first.
That last round.
He did 50% on game start.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I just realized he has the same costume as the other one.
Fight.
The amount of times I've been hit by that while trying to fight BrawlPro dude.
I'm sorry.
Nice.
Get up.
Wait.
You can do that?
What the fuck.
You can flip him?
Yeah.
I saw that.
That hit him.
Yo.
It just rotated him.
What the fuck.
That's a move.
He was done on that side.
Yeah.
What works at five guys.
Holy shit man.
Like a pancake.
The fact that even Cody didn't know you can flip.
I've never seen that.
It did no damage.
Can you stop comboing man?
Dude that's crazy.
That's his character man.
He's just touch of death.
Rotate him again.
Wow.
It's hard to deal with Brian when he gets walled.
He's gonna get walled.
Deal with Brian at the wall.
It's a really tough stage I think.
Yeah.
This stage is fucking scrub lord stage.
Oh.
Yeah even though.
Huge.
Nice.
Nice job.
That's huge.
Good shit.
Mmm.
Man these combos.
At least he doesn't get bounced.
He never charges that one.
Oh my god let him breathe.
Oops.
There's a bug on the floor.
Yeah.
Bug break.
Him hate spiders.
Oh.
So scary.
Ain't no way coaches are doing spring kicks.
Oh.
Oh my god.
And again.
Oh.
Oh my goodness.
Look at those kicks.
Nice.
Oh.
That wave dash back.
F smash?
Cracked.
F sma- Fonsep.
Fonsep.
Good shit.
Let's get off this stage bro.
That was an easy one.
Let me out.
Let me out of this place.
Are we on stream?
Nah I don't think so.
No we're not.
We were last round.
I think stage one is stream.
Nice.
The roll.
Waldemort?
I'll be able to do that one day.
Good shit.
Dammit.
Wow that's nuts.
Dude.
Ryan is relentless.
Round two.
Fight.
Nice.
Hehehe.
Count.
Oh nice.
Alright we got a wall.
Nice.
Good shit.
Where'd Blood's base go?
Send him to the hospital.
I know I'm crazy under that mask.
He ain't got no teeth.
Hmm.
Good shit.
Oh nice.
Oh.
Oh my goodness.
That's a nice punish.
I love that.
I love that when it happens in the game.
Oh.
Oh no.
I mean shit happens whatever.
It's alright you're still alive.
It's
getting a little close.
Oh.
I got this.
Oh oh!
Oh my.
Oh nice!
It's ok.
He gave you two chances.
For Bryan two times.
He parried it twice to let him know he could.
Yeah yeah.
Again.
Just to make a statement.
I'm in.
Surely they won't predict another low.
They'll never learn.
Nice.
The Doki!
The Doki LOL.
Learnings for chumps.
Guess for your life, LickyPie.
Nice job.
F***ing guess for game, bro.
God bless.
On that stage too?
He's talented.
Let's go BP.
Bro Pro Team is on top right now.
If you just didn't get hit by those kicks he did, the little jump shit, it would have been way...
Because he would just pop that at start, you know?
Yeah, I can explain too.
When I'm f***ing...
You know when he rage-rided me at the wall and I did like a back two randomly?
Yeah.
It snapped back on my stick.
So if I fling forward, forward, it'll go the opposite direction because of the flick.
And then the same with right there at the Shining Wizard at the end.
I flicked it forward three times really fast and then it flicked back and reset neutral.
And I'm like, oh my god.
So I have to be careful.
That's all.
Oh, that was crazy though.
That second low parry, that was so crazy.
Shit bro.
Yeah, I can't believe you got two of them.
I thought you f***ed up.
I was like, shit, we...
Guys, I think he wants to fight me again.
I'm going to fight Brock's box again.
He literally joined the lobby as I was checkmarked because I was like, oh, I'm going to fight Tone.
But Tone didn't win.
Dude, Raiditz lost to James Chie...
I got to watch these sets.
I got to...
That's f***ing crazy.
There's so much content to watch once we're f***ing done.
Okay.
I'm going to go back to the chat.
Get ready for the next battle.
Time to watch the rematch.
I guess this is a rematch.
Maybe the...
Salty runback.
I like that.
I like...
I like how boxbox is a f***ing gamer about it.
Yeah, he's a...
He's a hardcore gamer, dude.
Fight!
He's like, let's go.
Where is this streaming at?
Boxbox's streaming?
F***ing bitch.
I don't even know what's going on.
I'm sorry.
I hate this guy.
The rage arts.
I'm going to use the bathroom real quick while you watch this rematch of the century.
He is evil.
He is special evil with it.
Nice watch.
Yeah, he did.
It was a close set, you know?
I feel like he was sandbagging when I was watching.
I don't know, man.
What was up with that?
He finished all the combos.
You drop them sometimes though, Slime.
The B&Bs.
And also, let's say you do the hopkick.
You'll do one back 2-1 in the hunting bear stance.
You could do two.
Back 2-1, back 2-1, then the bear stance.
Right.
If I want to do it, I shouldn't in the first place.
Yeah.
We are on stage 3 now.
Okay.
Oh, they already made the lobby.
Jeez.
Yeah, we are set.
Lobby.
Does Matt and I take a game off?
Sure.
Oh, a game.
Okay, I'm back.
My devil chain?
He beat my devil chain while we were coaching.
Oh, no.
Beginner's ball.
I don't know if he wants to fight me again.
Okay.
Sorry, I have to finish this set.
I don't know what's going on.
He wants to fight.
Let's do it.
Lobby's up.
Oh, the lobby's up?
Yeah, it's up.
That was so fast.
Yeah, they're just moving through it.
Yeah.
We got two more...
Two more sets.
That was the fastest one yet.
What the hell?
I'm like stuck in a loading screen.
I'm in.
Are you playing the floor rank?
I can't even get into the lobby.
It's me.
Unfortunately.
Yeah, mine was a little fucky.
Miles with that Arizona host.
Let's see.
I'll just join again.
See if it...
Any fellow yellows in the team?
Maybe I will restart my game.
Maybe some bronze in the team.
Okay,
I'll just go with the same.
Not everybody's here, so we have lots of time.
Yeah.
So Doki, how's your first Sajam Slam so far?
I think it's pretty fun.
It's been pretty fun so far.
Yeah.
I'm learning.
I haven't hit my ceiling yet.
I've been all these other newbies...
They're already close to the ceiling.
You're definitely not at your ceiling yet.
Yeah.
Oh, you're still there.
Yeah, on the challenge it says that we lost to MYK, so I'm trying to get that swapped.
Oh my god.
Oh, there's like a wrong score?
Or...
Yeah, it says MYK beat us 3-2.
Oh.
Rigged.
Oh, I see.
Somebody bribed the coaches.
If that's how we... if that's what they want... shit.
I'll wire something up.
Wire some money real quick to Seijam.
Give 50 subs.
Remember slime, when you didn't fill out the stupid evo form?
I'm very wealthy, don't worry about me.
You can just do a $40 flight.
Wait, $40?
Wait, what?
Spirit flights are like double digits.
What are you... what are you...
$40?
And Seijam's like, no bro, I got you.
And it's like, Jesus, he's mad.
He should be dead.
On the street.
Oh fuck, why do I never focus on these?
Sorry.
I forgot about the hotel.
How do you... where are you gonna sleep?
I don't know bro.
I'll figure it out.
Oh!
Yay!
Yippee!
Wait, you can cook this guy.
I told you!
I haven't hit my ceiling yet!
All I can do is up!
All I can go is up!
They've hit their ceiling!
I haven't!
Look at him flail around.
He's too fast.
He's just slowly advancing.
That was like the Simpsons scene.
And if you get hit, it's your fault.
That's literally Jaguarmills.
Unironically, you seem to be better.
Is he gonna duck?
Oh wait, I messed that up.
Jk.
Will he duck this time?
Your 1 plus 2 is so slow.
We'll work on that though.
I'll get better.
I swear I'll get better.
Oh my god, she's kicking the shit out of him.
I told you!
If you hit 3 leg drops, the set is over.
Creaky!
No!
I keep messing that up!
But it's okay, he's dead.
This thing is freaky, dude.
When will you learn?
You never learn!
Just like me!
Never mind.
Never mind, guys.
Okay.
No!
He's learning, guys.
I don't understand.
Guys, I don't understand.
How is he learning?
Kick him in the head again!
Yes!
That's fucking right!
I'm gonna stab you!
What else?
His legs are broken!
You can't afford your hospital bill!
That's Joe Rogan yelling armbar, armbar.
You know what?
I'll take that.
I'll take those.
You'll take two!
Oh shit, really?
I'm gonna take him all the way?
Waiter, one more, please.
Will he expect this?
Oh, he did.
Okay, but will he expect this?
Oh my fucking god.
This dude doubles your prowess, by the way.
I know!
That's what I'm saying!
You're melting him!
Bro, it's like the mental game.
He knows, too.
He's like, how am I...
Fight or flight, doki.
This is it!
Oh my god!
I'll be mad, bro!
I'll be mad!
Dude, this is so good.
You're so straight in front of everyone at Times Square!
I know!
He's so embarrassed!
Like, how are you doing?
How are you letting me do this to you?
I'll convert my goat.
What the fuck?
Okay, now he's actually mad.
He has to be pissed.
Yup, onto the street.
Bro, why are you not learning?
Why are you not learning?
Oh my fucking god.
Doki Bird can beat anyone who doesn't learn.
Let's go.
That's it.
That's really it.
If you don't learn, I can take advantage of it.
He literally stood up and won!
I've never seen that!
He was on the ground!
Please!
I've done this move 20 times!
I think we back story here actually.
I think we do a couple back threes.
Not now.
Hello.
Is that it?
I wouldn't give!
Let's go!
I wouldn't give against a red!
Nice job!
I got one!
That's what the fuck I'm talking about.
Good shit.
I'd like to dedicate this win to my coach.
Coney.
Coach Coney?
You're welcome.
Hey, more alley kicks next time.
Yeah, thanks Coney.
Well, I just got cooked for no reason.
But what about the other one?
I'm not the fighter fight.
Some things you can teach, VP.
Some things you can't teach.
It's all intuition.
Look at that.
He must be so mad.
Oh, I'd be furious.
Let's pull up his stream.
Let's confirm these theories.
A little hypothetical.
Wait, who am I fighting?
Who are you fighting?
I thought I was fighting...
Am I fighting a Yoshi?
I think I'm fighting Zentreya.
It's just another public ass lobby for some reason.
Oh, I see.
I'm a Zentreya.
They should just have me make these.
I know I fucked up the first one.
That's mad annoying.
Alright, let's get it.
Someone kick this guy.
Dude, that Brawl Pro clip where someone's calling you Hollywood.
And you're like, I'm not fucking Hollywood.
He thinks he's better than everyone.
No, I don't.
And there's like this big pause and you're like, Except Oli, I'm way better than him.
But that's it.
Dude, it's so funny.
Just hitting on him for no reason.
I live for the Brawl Pro Oli fucking beef.
So fucking funny.
I fucking hate that guy, man.
I just saw him the other day.
He's like, what did you say fuck beef for?
Oh god.
I hope I'm in that man's head right now.
Oh, he's thinking about that L.
He's gonna train hard for that.
He's like, I got killed by a yellow?
June Kazama.
Oh my god.
His name is John Cena.
It's John Cena.
Yeah, I'm gonna dare you.
Luigi?
Super Luigi.
Luigi got a big pat.
I called him Luigi too during the first thing.
He did that.
I don't listen to hip hop much.
I don't know.
This is how I know you're fucking funny as shit.
John, my favorite character from Nintendo.
John Luigi.
Oh my, all these wakeups.
That's my coach.
Oh my lord.
Wakeup buttons running through your gut right now.
Wakeup buttons, huh?
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Yo, that shoulder went...
Two times today.
Bro, does Zen learn?
Nice!
Yeah, cause that's low mid.
Okay.
That's supposed to be a big win, but I didn't see it.
The fuck is that?
Wow.
Oh, nice.
Woo!
Funny might just be my go, dude.
Oh my goodness, brother!
I got it.
Do it again!
It's just always wakeups, man.
You win.
I'm watching Can-Cans.
Round one.
Fight.
Oh my god.
I gotta be slow eventually.
Good.
Oh.
We're never playing.
And no more wake up balls.
I said no more wake up balls!
That's enough!
Do it again!
I learned it.
You learned it mid-match.
It's forever ingrained.
Fight.
What?
Stop!
What the fuck?
Now she's rotationing.
Nice.
No way, we're still getting up with buttons.
I just assume it's over.
You don't learn.
I got three of those.
Two very new ideas.
I got three.
Round three.
Fight.
Oh my god, you're so good.
This really is John Cena.
Fuck!
Yeah.
John Cena pre-radiate Luigi.
Wait, that was clean from the thing.
Oh, yeah that's sidestep.
Oh, fuck.
Look at you.
Look at my big baby boy.
Nice!
My big baby poobah.
That's him!
It's on my end.
It's okay.
You just want to keep it close.
Nice!
Oh, shit.
It's my turn.
It's still my turn.
Cooked.
Simply cooked.
That's our coach!
Yeah, whatever.
It's cool.
Yeah, don't be just do that.
You too, bro.
Yeah, you too, bro.
You were there too.
I hope you guys learned something.
Oh my god, I learned.
I'm taking notes right now.
Morciata, a very scary player.
You got this, dude.
Yeah, it's...
They play hella like...
I don't know how to describe it.
But solid.
Okay.
Real Tekken?
They play real Tekken, quote unquote.
So, maybe you want to cheese them out.
Wait, what does real Tekken mean?
He doesn't do any like...
weirdo moves.
He just kind of pokes.
Goes for a launcher every now and then.
Oh, is it Sifter?
So he's there to tilt you.
Oh, Morciata.
Is this Sifter's team?
Shifter?
Was it really that funny when I said Sifter?
You just started giggling, bro.
Dude, I was not the only one laughing, man.
Okay, but still, I think you started it.
That shit was silly.
Yeah, let's feel this out.
I'm not gonna be throwing out willy-nilly stuff.
Let's get it.
Round one.
Fight.
Oh, can't be eating that.
You're a kitchen.
Kitchen cousins.
Kitchen cousins?
I don't even stream, I'm a YouTuber, let me grow.
I'm a YouTuber too!
That's how you know how I feel!
Tech is not even your main content!
I'm sleepy there!
I'm taking a nap real quick.
What is happening there?
He's just poking.
Jin is so weird because he's so basic but also so crippled.
Wait, that's a 1 plus 2.
That's a 2.
It's a 2?
Oh my god, he has a main character buff, it's not fair.
It's okay, we cook.
Nice, you can wall combo here.
Butt too, you could still have done the butt.
That's alright, we get the reset, get more dubs.
That dude is funny!
He doesn't know how to get up.
Oh, come on.
You do.
Oh wow.
Nice grab.
Oh god.
I've never seen this kick that I'm getting hit with in my whole fucking life.
That's a badass, across the map, counter hit launcher.
Fuck.
Show me your moves now.
So I'm getting hit with like a 5x5 unit.
Like the third move.
What is that?
Like he's hitting me with two hits and then that kick.
Oh, you mean the downward kick?
No, that kick that just like counter hits me.
Oh.
That's a move on its own, it's his forward 4.
Yeah, it's a solo move.
It's just a counter hit launcher, full screen.
Yeah, um...
You can power crush it or you can whiff punish it, but it's a really good move, yeah.
He just pushes you off.
I'm tired.
Oh, what a turn.
It's okay.
Got the advantage.
Oh my god.
He likes having no keys.
I don't have any fucking strings.
Slap him!
Oh.
Slap him.
Yeah.
Nice running.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god, nom.
Oh!
Nice.
Holy shit.
Three... fight.
Come on.
Two...
Six...
He's only grabbing with the two grab.
Yeah.
Fight.
What a...
Oh!
Nice.
Why am I getting fucking turned around?
I don't know what to do.
You press 1 plus 2, that's why he does that.
Oh, he didn't let go.
You hit it?
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Wow!
Maybe you can hit and then cancel it?
And then fish?
I don't know, but the wall is right there.
Yeah, I'll give it a shot.
Okay.
Yes, sir.
Yours comes out first.
No.
Oh!
That's safe?
Yeah, that's really solid.
That's close.
Oh my god, I hate that fucking character so much.
So can you download him?
We got hella info on this guy.
Yeah.
Yeah, Jin is so weird, cause he's not like, spamming, like warring or whatever, but he still feels so like...
I don't know.
It's just moves.
I don't know how to play.
Oh yeah, he's good.
He has really good buttons.
For sure.
100%.
Oh man.
Whose team is this?
Oh, this is Miles' team.
Okay.
I've never fought this guy in my life.
He probably makes them very fast.
I have no data on this guy.
Please leave.
You said that from FD.
Yeah, you said that from Eddie.
Yeah, but this guy was in a boxbox.
This one's a little different.
Yeah, I can hear you.
No, we heard you.
We heard you.
Yeah, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Who came up with Jack Jesus?
Was it just someone's chat?
I think it was Dayjam.
I have no idea.
Might have been a chat.
Might have been... Why did he even say that?
You don't... I don't know.
He literally said, they call him Jack Jesus.
Whose day?
Yeah, who is that?
Well, now they do.
He implanted the shit.
Yeah, I've never fought this guy.
We'll try.
Have you fought Alyssa?
A little bit.
I kinda know.
Not really.
We'll see.
What the hell?
She can't see!
What the heck?
Wait!
No, I'm behind!
Oh, what the fuck?
That's an SCP.
She's scary.
Oh my god, what's going on with my game?
Woo!
My speed.
Spectator bugged so hard, I went zoom.
Yeah, it's so goofy when that happens.
Volcano!
Nice!
Oh, nice!
Oh, you see how he got up wrong there?
Yeah, that's the inner formation.
And you were scared!
You got up wrong!
Oh my god.
Oh, he's getting up wrong.
He's getting looped with it.
Plague up correctly, bro!
Whoops, whoops, whoops, whoops, whoops, whoops, whoops.
I'm never gonna chill.
Alright, bro.
I love this character.
So fun.
Nice.
Oh, bound!
Yo!
The side wall maybe.
Oh, that side step!
Yeah, we have to recognize side wall.
You know what I mean.
Epic, dude.
What?
Yeah, get her out of that.
I can't believe that works.
That always works!
They'll never learn.
This team doesn't learn.
Oh, fuck!
No, 1 plus 2.
1 plus 2.
Oh.
Nice.
Drop the satellite.
Punish?
Ah, sorry.
I didn't know it was punishable.
Okay.
Oh, it hits still.
Oh, is that?
Oh, god.
Now you know why I was confused.
I can tell that Kony is way behind.
I'm very behind.
You know, the biggest mistake?
I gotta restart this PC.
You dropped the satellite and we're like 4 seconds ahead of you.
I'm watching like a John Woo film.
Oh, you get your HP back.
I know, right?
It's a hard counter now.
Genuinely.
It's good to armor, Alyssa.
I forgot about that.
Oh, fuck.
This is close, man.
I don't know what this is.
Damn, this guy is pretty good.
He hit confirm that too.
That was nice.
Woo!
A lot of chip too.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, no.
She downloaded you.
Oh, my.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm gonna go back to the game.
It's a lot of HP back.
Fuck.
Okay, understood.
I can fix this.
You win.
It's okay.
You can download her back.
Is that hopkick?
How punishable?
13?
Minus 13.
Okay.
Yeah.
So you have a shoulder or you can do your 2-3 thing.
You just can't forward 1-1, I think.
Okay.
Is it 0-1 or 1-1?
0-1.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can 1-1.
Yeah, 1-1.
Awesome.
Fuck.
She gets up wrong.
Oh, yeah.
It's hard to do.
I think I need a 2-jab more.
I'm gonna try to see if it works.
Oh, my lord.
The HP.
That's insane.
Oh, my god.
She's so dead.
You get so much health back.
That's absurd.
Nice step.
Yeah, that was good.
Oh, shit.
That's launch, huh?
If I duck it?
You have to stay ducking.
Yes.
Low-high.
It jails though.
What if I duck the...
or I get hit by the high?
What happens?
Is it like...
You know the frames on it?
I don't know the frames, but it's like neutral-ish.
Oh, it's clean.
Yeah!
Yeah, it is neutral.
It is neutral, but it does chip damage.
I don't know what to do here.
He's gonna do some random-ass shit.
You're gonna run up and blog.
Punish.
Nice punish!
Oh, fuck!
Ah, bitch!
Wow!
We take that.
We take it.
We love that.
Yeah, yeah.
Your head!
So crazy.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Break it.
Yes!
Oh my god, don't let her get up!
This character is fucking insane.
I know, right?
What the fuck is that?
Oh my god.
He's just inventing moves.
This is unbelievable.
You downloaded her back!
Every time Jack is on screen, the screen is shaking!
I'm getting dizzy.
Oh my god.
The dizzy meter.
Eddie's dizzy meter was so stupid.
I got you, dude.
Mat, you can duck her one-one.
Oh, my!
Nice!
Oh!
Oh wow the counter hit you dead.
Oh my gosh nice.
Nice!
First win.
Good shit.
What the fuck was that roll man?
What is this?
Okay man!
That's what you do!
That's you!
That's what you do to people!
Get back to her!
I'll get it I'll get it I'll get it.
Look what you're doing!
Look at you!
I'm going.
Did you hit that?
Oh big.
Yeah!
That's free right?
She can't get upstairs.
What's the mix?
Ah he might rage art if you run up into nothing.
Maybe run up into nothing.
And then the heat dash mix.
What a fuck.
Oh my god.
Oh nice!
That was cute.
You got cute with it.
I like that.
I think he's going to go low at the walls and then I'm just going to try and get the back.
Down 4 1 plus 2 maybe?
Oh fuck.
Oh wow.
Well we didn't guess right there.
We all died.
Team every.
Nice.
Okay.
Pretty good.
Fight!
Oh my god.
Oh I can't believe she died.
No way!
Oh my gosh no.
She should die there.
Yeah right.
The head's off.
Yeah.
That's her head.
Come on man.
Oh my god.
Okay I'll try.
Alright.
It's like a self destruct.
Lock in.
Oh no blue spark.
Oh so no combo?
No.
It's okay.
Oh what a back step.
Nice bro.
Nice!
Oh shit.
Oh nice.
Get out of here bro.
That's right!
There he goes!
Let's fucking go.
Fun fucking shit dude.
He's the end.
He's the anchor man.
He's the anchor.
Dude.
A trump card.
Defending and muting is not a good idea during these sets because dude I think it's good like the down how you duck that string and launch them for it.
That was good.
I mean it made sense with low high.
Good shit bro.
Yeah.
Good shit.
Okay brawpos gotta bring it back.
Bring back all the king wins.
Oh fuck I have to play?
Why do I have to play again?
Fuck.
Yeah keep the king streak.
Get us more points coach.
Go get us more points.
Yeah.
No no it's it's.
It's a good idea.
I mean we lost 3-1 right?
Thanks chat.
We lost 3-1.
Yeah but if he loses this he's like the weakest king player out of all of us.
That is true.
Cause all the other kings won their match.
That's actually true.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Didn't think of it like that.
Some coach.
Dude she's good bro.
What do you want me to do?
I just want you not to get sunned by Kony and Doki.
Yeah.
Come on.
That's your job.
You can't just break the king streak.
I'm just gonna go get some points.
You wanted to get said- I'd be the hell out of this pile.
This is a lot of added pressure that I don't need here.
We just came for secret rankings.
We're prepping you for the finals!
We're prepping you for the fin- for the finals!
Press one if you won your set.
One.
I didn't even lose ya bro.
Earn that one bro.
Earn that one.
One.
Fight.
Just kick him off?
No.
Oh.
Foggy.
We got all the blocks.
Oh, nice!
That's a lot of neutral.
Yeah.
He does not lose.
Oh, let's go.
She has to break those.
If she's not breaking those, then...
Yeah.
That's all me, baby.
Swing!
Swing that goal!
Five more.
Let's go.
Keep that streak.
Good shot.
Oh.
Nice.
Yeah, bro is sleeping.
Good shot.
Oh, she broke two.
I'll be able to do that too.
Oh, nice.
Really?
Even more?
What the fuck?
Nice.
That's... right there.
I love that shove move from King.
Yeah.
It's like a high school, like, back of the high school near the flagpole move.
Oh, rotated!
Get rotated.
That move is so good and I never use it.
It basically just puts you in plus.
Just up close.
It's so good.
Wow.
I mean, what a walk.
Nice!
Whoa!
What a duck!
Hey.
Cup!
Oh, my God!
See?
The added pressure makes you a better player.
He's stronger!
Yeah!
You're stronger!
He's that sweating, sweating Key and Peele gif.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm dying over here.
Really?
But you win!
You win!
You're winning the round robin one, the ones that don't matter.
This is what matters.
I said this first slam.
We absolutely dominated round robin.
Who cares?
You know?
What do the points even do?
Is that seeding or?
Yeah.
So, like, I guess whoever has the most points gets better seeding or whatever.
So, the way this works...
We should be able to choose our own opponents.
Only us two?
Yeah.
Matt, fight half the club.
The one with the most points gets to choose who wants to fight.
I choose Mattman against everyone.
We just keep putting in Matt.
I can beat some of the coaches.
He's just sweating and tired.
Oh, you're just sweating and tired?
Every other person is...
I don't think I can win, but the coaches, you're positive.
Okay.
Dude, Amaz is too random.
I can't.
But you didn't win.
Fight.
Nice.
I feel like if you win the most points, we should get, like, one bye game where we just don't fight any of them.
I'm pretty sure that's what's going to happen.
That's fine.
That's what happens.
Wait, really?
Yeah, we get a bye.
Yeah.
It's a bracket at the end, but there's one more round robin day.
The points on Friday are one more.
Yeah, yeah.
So basically, the top two teams will get, like, a bye.
Okay.
We got a bye last time.
Yeah.
You're in good company, though.
Oh, my God.
I haven't hit my ceiling yet.
Nice.
I mean, just look how much we're dominating, you know?
Like...
Oh, first hit.
Iki-Mas.
I want to know how pissed that guy was.
Wow.
Fight.
How would that... someone in chat, my chat was like, she's a robot?
Why does that even hurt?
And I think that's a good question.
Because she has...
Well, her circuits are like...
Maybe she's programmed to feel pain.
Maybe her bar is just her being really annoyed.
Her annoyed bar.
Yeah.
Like, oh, that's annoying.
If you annoy her enough, she overheats.
Shutting down.
The noise of being annoyed.
Yeah.
It sucks.
Does not cook, dude.
Why would you ever give robots pain sensors?
That's so fucked up.
She's taking the arms off.
It's so funny.
Is that what that is?
It's gonna help me.
I was like, what is he dropping on the ground?
They should make it so Alyssa self-destructs when she gets KO'd.
Oh my God.
That would be so good.
Drop for a double KO.
It's like a D.Va bomb.
Oh, I had double.
Ow.
Wow!
Oh!
I saw you play Marvel Rivals, did you like it?
Yeah, it was really fun.
I think it like...
I think like... it feels more casual though.
Because of the third person.
Yeah, I tried playing it yesterday and I felt the same.
I think if it was like first person, it would be more competitive.
Yeah, the third person aspect is kinda weird though.
That's a mobile game, right?
They're trying to make it for phones too.
I won't be surprised!
Because it's like NetEase.
I played a little bit of it and I was like, this is okay, you know?
I think it's not competitive, but more so for like...
for fun.
I just thought it was funny that like all the old Overwatch players were grinding... were six stacking rank and getting top 10.
Yeah, you got Sinatraa and shit just fucking dominating.
Yeah!
All the Overwatch players, the old ones, are like top 20 in Marvel Rivals.
Because all they do is six stack and bully the poor players.
We are not breaking one.
Not now, not ever.
Oh wow.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, what the fuck?
What is that move?
You can't even tell them to talk to coach.
Like, you are the coach!
Yeah!
Shit off me.
Those are arms.
Yeah, yeah, they're her arms.
If you tech her 1 plus 2, she puts her head in your hand.
And then you just put it back on her neck.
Like, not that.
Wait, you can put it back on her head?
Yeah, yeah.
If he techs that grab, he puts it back on her.
Wait, that's so cool.
It's really funny.
Coach, show us that.
He was flabbergasted that he didn't tech it.
Got it.
I thought I pressed it.
I wanna see it.
Fight!
Just tech it perfectly.
You got this.
Nice.
Her defense is really good.
Oh, nice.
Oh!
Oh my god.
You waited too.
Every button on the controller.
That fucking delay too.
A buffet of options.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Shit!
The prediction!
Oh my gosh!
That's the brain destroyer, yeah.
Oh my god.
Her mental's gone after seeing that.
I mean, mine would be.
Coach, platform.
Oh wow.
You hit that?
Nice!
She has her rage art too, though.
She's never gonna use it.
She doesn't pop that.
She would not.
I told you!
I read her inputs.
She would...
I'm in her PC.
That's...
You took damage from that?
Oh, we're doing it again?
Oh, not this time, though.
Yeah, I know.
No way, the bridge?
What?
What is this move?
Oh!
Oh my god!
My leg!
What the fuck kind of move was that?
You think I could do that?
Miles, get up!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Nice!
The king streak continues!
Coach, good adaptation.
That was beautiful.
That's 4-1, baby!
Nice job.
We 4-1'd that shit.
Let's go!
We're...
Woo!
I was... like, in the second game, I started enjoying the conversation.
Maybe it's too much.
I know, you were paying attention to the Overwatch.
Yeah!
I could see you, like, not paying attention.
Was I awful?
My chat's just like, BP?
Question mark?
BP?
I was thinking about Dive versus Brawl.
Oh my god, guys, we all won a match!
That's fucking...
Yeah, all of us!
That's true!
Yeah!
We all won one!
I had to win that.
I would've gotten fired.
On the king team.
Yeah, I wouldn't listen to you anymore if you lost that.
Oh, she said she's teleporting back.
Am I?
I mean, I'm on Fiverr.
I don't fucking know, dude.
Check the stream, I guess.
We did it, guys.
We have one more left, right?
I think one more, yeah.
One more team, and then we can all fuck off.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're against Kaiser's team.
You're on Fiverr?
Yeah.
Are they making the lobby now?
We have time to warm up or nah?
They'll do a quick match.
It's not a big deal.
And you can join us, whatever.
Alright, yeah.
I'm gonna make them wait for me.
Yeah, just be like, I'm fucking Doki Bird.
Chill the fuck out while I play my quick match.
Yeah, chill out, guys.
Kazuyamishima.
You know what?
I already won my one game.
That was my goal.
Now I can coast.
Oh my god, guys!
I won a game!
Are you that proud of me?
I did it!
Yeah, because they're like a setting that you're supposed to set it to, to make it so that you don't win.
What the fuck is...
Guys, I swear I'll plug me in my PC tomorrow.
I swear I'll plug me in my PC tomorrow.
I swear.
We did it!
You guys are believers, right?
You guys all believe in me?
You still have...
Oh, she's saying it was 3 frame rollback.
But then, there's nothing you can really do about that.
That's just what it is.
Guys, I promise.
It was more than 3 frames.
That was like the PS4 cannot win.
I understand what's happening.
I guess it's PS5.
It felt like PS4.
Okay, I wanna practice this.
Because I wanna be able to do this one day.
Guys, I...
I can only go up.
I'm just telling her to switch it to standard.
I should do that too.
I should change the map.
I don't like this map.
It's too short.
Do the king bridge.
The what?
I saw it.
But I don't know if you guys understand.
I don't know how that is done.
Yeah, once I got the PC plugged in.
I'll be able to pull off the king bridge.
I promise on that.
Guys, I promise.
I'll plug in the PC.
It's by tomorrow.
I got like the first step done.
I like unboxed it.
Do they want us right into the next one?
Like, right now?
Right now?
Are we hanging out?
I don't know.
I'm doing quick match until someone says something.
Yeah, me too.
I'm doing quick match right now.
Who's this girl?
Oh my gosh, she has five wins.
I'm fucked.
Okay.
Please, can I do that combo my coach is trying to teach me?
Please.
I'm trying to do this combo that my coach is trying to teach me.
I don't care.
I'm in a quick match.
Please.
There you go.
No!
I fucked it up!
Please, please.
I need to do this combo.
I don't care if I lose this.
Let me do this combo.
Don't make me pull off this.
Oh, never mind.
You can just kill me.
Please.
Please, I just want to pull off this one combo.
I did it!
I pulled it off in game!
Oh my god!
Nothing matters anymore.
Now you die.
I pulled it off.
Oh shit.
No, never mind.
I thought she would keep.
Yay!
That's all I wanted.
Please.
Oh!
I pulled it off again!
And then...
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
I thought she would let me keep doing this on her.
Guys.
Guys, this is actually... I need you guys to know that was the first time I've ever pulled that combo off.
Like, actually.
The very first time.
Red.
Mayo.
Like, now I can actually not care.
There are out of five wins in game streak!
There's no way!
There's new player!
Oh god.
Please, give me a down...
Forward, forward, neutral.
Please.
Please, that's the other combo I want to learn.
Oh my god.
Don't make me do this on you.
Now I can focus on improving my other stuff!
Like blocking!
Because what the fuck is blocking?
There we go.
Guys, I blocked.
Guys, I...
Guys, I fucked around.
I was trying to learn how to block.
Guys...
Oh, fuck!
Guys, okay, look.
The goal was to block nothing else.
I did not need to learn anything else.
It was just about learning the blocks.
We lost, but we learned.
We actually hit that combo for the first time against a real player.
I will learn how to...
True, it's a fighting game, not a blocking game.
That is true.
All I wanted was to really hit this move.
That's all I wanted.
And also like this.
This is the next goal.
Being able to hit this and then this.
Next goal!
Being able to hit that on a real player.
And then...
Oh, no, that's the smash.
Okay.
Got that.
No, not that!
One day.
Blocking is disabled in this game.
Alright.
It's okay.
Oh, no.
It's an eddy.
Death cradle next.
You see, my coach made me remove the keybind to do the death cradle.
Because I kept accidentally pressing it and it's not good.
It was not good that I kept accidentally pressing it.
Because it's a key charge.
So I had to unbind it because of it.
Oh, please.
Eddie, please.
Please have mercy.
Oh!
Goodbye.
It's very predictable.
Not for that one guy I beat.
It might be predictable for you.
But I beat that one guy.
And he still didn't learn.
Oh, wait.
He actually blocked that.
I could have grappled him.
Please block.
Okay.
How much?
Block.
Pay to block.
Okay.
They want me to start blocking.
So, like, can you please...
Okay.
It's okay.
It's a quick play.
There's no stakes involved.
Pay to block.
This time.
Yeah!
I noticed you stopped blocking me!
Oh, shit.
Never mind.
JK.
Oh, no.
Guys.
Yay!
Come on.
Oh, shit.
I thought you were gonna stay on the ground.
Pay to block.
And then lose.
Hey, look.
I did one that two sets there.
Goodbye.
I'm a one and done.
Get ready for the next battle.
Thank you for blocking.
Every dollar I block once.
Yay!
Alright.
Goodbye.
I still need to learn...
I need to get that neutral...
neutral grab, correct?
You're never allowed to block.
This is how Doki becomes a multi-billionaire.
Look, guys.
It's a hard life out there being cunting.
Wait.
I'm here.
Sorry.
You gotta make some economic decisions.
Fight!
Are we ready?
What room is this?
Stage?
Oh, no.
I don't know.
I haven't been at it yet.
Oh, okay.
Cause SageM was like, oh, we have a Kingmare coming up Doki.
And I was like, oh, shit.
Oh, yay.
Boom!
The only move I know!
And this one too!
See?
I blocked!
There you go.
Fight!
Three moves that I know!
You gotta learn how to block them!
And then the steps!
That's right!
Can she juggle?
That is such a good question.
Easy.
Yeah, if I find myself losing, just grab.
Look at this.
The three moves that I need to know.
Do you guys think they're gonna analyze me and realize I only do literally three moves?
Yes!
Guys, there's no way they're gonna analyze me, right?
And like, realize that.
There's no fucking way.
If you need help...
Oh, yeah, I definitely need.
There's no way!
After Round Robin 1?
No.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, she already learned after like, 1.
How did she know?
It's not like I've been doing that like, this entire time.
No fucking way.
Oh shit.
Guys, I think she learned.
It's actually crazy.
You blocked!
I'm proud of you!
Team Kaiser.
Oh shit.
Okay, we got it.
Our match starts.
Our match is starting.
Back swing fucking demon, dude.
Yeah, I know about that.
Burn!
Oh shit.
Please, let me live.
Please.
She's not gonna duck.
You know how I know that?
Because she also doesn't learn.
Yeah, I'm kidding.
Alright.
Let's see.
Uh...
Oh, who's making the lobby?
They pinged us.
So, I don't...
Let's see.
Are we back on?
We're gonna be on the mainstream.
Apparently.
Yeah.
We're gonna be on the big screen, guys!
We're gonna be famous!
The guy I'm playing has not dropped a game, apparently.
He's nice.
Then you're gonna drop his game.
Sure no, I think.
Sure no, solid.
This is it.
You're gonna make him regret it.
It'll be fine.
I believe.
So, you say he's one of the best third seeds.
Along with Kony.
Okay.
If I lose data...
Oh yeah!
Cerno!
I know Cerno.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's been a streamer for a fucking long time.
Hasn't he?
He's like one of the OGs.
Is he?
I see him around Tekken streams.
Even before the Sajan thing was even a thing.
I know he's been around for a very long time.
Tekken wasn't his content.
He used to do other stuff.
Really?
That's sick.
Oh, code's up.
Stage 1.
Here we go.
Don't worry.
I won't leak the code, guys.
There's a password.
I will.
Oh.
I almost.
It's okay.
The code is 8543, guys.
Oh my god.
Why would you do that to us?
No, it's definitely 9710.
Go ahead and join up.
Yeah, yeah.
Definitely.
Imagine just one digit off.
And get 9712.
Guys, when you join...
When you join the lobby, the code is right there.
Oh yeah, it is.
Oh my god.
Wait, really?
Wait, it is.
Oh, it's a cloud, man.
Okay, okay.
We're all clouds.
That's how you know we're content creator brain.
That's really good.
We're all clouds.
Everyone's like, yeah, make sure there's a code.
Now we know that Cody was unironically like...
Yeah, that was such a move, Cody.
I'm telling the truth, bro.
I'm telling the truth.
That's like when I have aces and they're like, you got aces?
And I'm like, yup.
I love my fans.
I want everybody to play.
Let's all get in here.
Oh yeah, let's join our room right now.
Doki, you can't do that.
You have more viewers than all of us combined.
You can't do that.
Wait, I want to be included.
No, my viewers get it.
Your viewers don't.
You have like 5,000 people in there.
You're not the same.
You have 5,000 people watching you.
My viewers are respectable.
Guys, join my lobby right now.
I bet your viewers are not respectable and are poor.
But don't do it.
I'm gonna go into my stream and drop a Twitch Prime or a tier 1.
They got no money.
They're not subbing to me.
They don't got it like that.
Hey, Koni's chat.
I also have a Twitch too.
It's at DokiBread on Twitch.
And you can drop me a sub there.
Game's starting!
You gotta focus!
You're about to play!
I never focus.
It costs no money whatsoever.
Everyone just chilling.
Everyone opening the jacket full of their potions and things to say.
Yo, go drop those subs!
The King here.
It's always queuing.
Double King!
Wait, who's higher?
He's higher than me!
Oh my god, he's licking the cup!
I'm gonna get distracted!
I saw a Charlie moment.
You saw what?
Wait, what?
Oh my god, Koba, you're king!
I'm getting distracted!
Getting distracted?
Yeah!
How am I supposed to focus?
I can't keep looking down without you.
Bro, I keep...
Bro, look at his pecs though.
He's like a Ken doll.
It's fine.
Wait, how would you know?
Have you seen what's underneath there?
How do you know?
I think it's my legs.
Don't keep focusing on the map!
What do you mean?
I am focusing!
You are winning quite a lot.
I can tell which one is you because you have clothes.
Fuck, okay, I'm not focusing anymore, guys.
This thing is naked in the middle of Times Square!
Oh my god, this is fucking Disney!
There are one of these in my life with...
Okay, alright, coach.
You gotta tell them.
We're gonna have to talk to the coach.
If I tell her press 1 or 2, then she'll stop playing and look at the controller for 5 seconds.
That is not true!
That is absolutely not true!
So I don't want to mess you up?
There's one!
That's how it is!
Stop!
Now I'm actually looking at the controller!
Don't look!
Oh my god, I'm winning!
Oh my god, you're messing with my groove!
Oh my god, double jab combo!
You guys are messing with my groove!
No more jabs!
I'm gonna be very serious!
Is this a serious time?
No, but then if I'm serious, then I'm gonna think!
He's focusing!
Watch this!
Serious gameplay!
For serious gamers!
No, it's so serious!
Please get away from me!
The spacing, holy...
Oh my goodness, talk about movement!
Good bait!
Nice!
Great poi king gameplay!
Look at that!
I told you!
The less I focus, the better I do!
Stajam's chat is like, Oh!
You guys didn't see Doki KBD just then?
I saw it, the spacing was crazy!
Bro, that was totally intentional too!
I think?
I don't know, I don't think when I'm playing sometimes.
Is that noticeable?
Instinct!
That just means you're a gamer.
Oh god, don't!
You're jinxing me guys!
Now I'm starting to think again!
This is bad!
Oh!
She's a king!
It's like she's a king player!
But she's not that much of a...
The amount of shunning with this!
Oh no!
It's cool, you're alive?
I dropped the elbow on the foot!
Ouch!
Fight!
It's like she knows, it's weird.
Oh my god!
God damn!
Hit that!
Oh no!
It's fine.
Oh no, she does that thing that you told me about!
Like my one move.
Does she duck though?
Oh she does.
Wait, you can do that?
What the god?
That's a mis- Explain!
Explain, coach!
Oh the donkey!
Oh!
Great!
I do!
Alright, run up and check this out.
Shining wizard.
Wait, what's shining wizard again?
The running grab!
Okay, okay, okay!
The tomahawk!
Where was it?
Looking on the giant channel of all the buttons.
Oh, she blocked!
You gotta press 1, x, or square.
I need to fucking stop doing that.
No!
Guys, the more I start thinking, the worse I'm doing.
I feel like.
Look at King's nipples.
I was doing better when I was distracted.
Oh no!
Good break!
Oh!
Okay!
Did I hit that?
That's crazy!
No!
Watch your run!
Try, now try, now try.
Alright, nice try, nice try.
Okay, I need to turn my brain off again.
He just can't be Natty.
Look at how vascular he looks.
I can't!
It's just so distracting!
I know that back looks crazy.
It's like all there.
Like one of those places is pimply.
I'll be a bit lower.
Round 1.
Fight!
Okay.
Nice!
Oh, no she did that thing that you taught me.
She is like 2.
Yeah, She is copying my moves.
You can dunk that remember when she runs at you.
Yes.
Yeah.
ioou L and N Oh, unlucky.
Oh!
What the fuck?
It's like she awkward king player.
Nice!
You want a time?
Hey, did I get that?
I did it.
Oh yeah.
Did I get that too?
Of course.
Oh my goodness!
Genius.
The level of mind games that are being played right now, I have no idea.
That's huge.
And it hurts more because he doesn't have close-up.
Yeah, that's true.
There's no padding.
There's no padding for her.
Oh no.
Nice.
Oh what?
She predicted me!
Remember you have to do the...
square.
That's your mid.
That's my mid.
I'm trying to explain properly.
The square.
Hold square right now.
Okay, I'm holding.
I'm holding.
There I did it.
That's what I'm talking about.
Oh my god.
I did it.
No, she fucking punches me in the nut and it hurts.
Yeah.
Because I have balls now.
The 4-4 neutral 2, Doki.
I don't know if you forgot about it.
Forgot what?
4-4 neutral 2.
That low she keeps hitting you with.
Oh fuck, 10 strings.
Oh my god.
You thought it was friendly.
We're doing strings.
Square, square, square, square.
Oh, never mind.
It's okay.
I didn't need it.
Okay.
It's okay.
I didn't need it.
This is the best matchup I've ever watched in my life.
That question.
I've never seen anything better.
What the fuck?
She bit my balls.
What?
How is that legal?
It's not.
Square, square, square, square.
I did it.
I learned.
Oh my god.
It's like I can learn.
Good adaptation.
Okay.
Nice.
It's fucking go.
Yeah.
She's fucking goaded.
I did it.
I beat a Tekken player.
She's been playing Tekken before I started playing Tekken.
Oh.
I'm so beast.
See, you guys just need to shout the controller icons.
Yeah, yeah.
Just order a Uniqlo shirt with a big blue button.
PlayStation Square.
It has to be upside down though.
So she can look down.
Like impact text.
Beware.
Just yell square, square, square.
We did it.
I got two matches in.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
This has got to turn off my brain.
Yeah.
You just got to become the king.
You have to hit the rage thing.
Yeah.
The rage button.
It's Reyna.
Okay.
He got this.
He matches a lot apparently.
Well.
Dick jab will be your best friend.
Dick jab into giant swing or just back three when he's rushing you maybe.
Woo.
I'm going to use the bathroom break.
I bet you can pull off one set.
I believe.
Did you make this picture, Kony?
I just saw.
Which one?
Oh no, Chatter did.
Thank you, Chatter.
This is so cool.
Oh, this shit is chugging.
Okay, never mind.
We're good.
I think we're good.
No buttons.
Oh my half life gone.
Mm-hmm.
Kitty mode, Reyna.
Oh my god.
Wow.
Come on, Super Mario King.
I remember this.
You have hate, Kony.
Keep in mind.
Oops.
Nice patience.
Honestly, both of you.
I was like it's going to be a match fest and it wasn't.
Fight.
Ugh.
Ball, coach.
Let's go.
Remember the square.
Yo, why don't these guys know how to avoid that?
Yo.
I'm going to go.
Oh.
Let's go keep the King streak alive.
Fight.
I know her strength.
You can hop kick that if you block it.
Yeah.
Nice.
Okay.
Good duck.
He's going to duck.
He's going to duck more than he doesn't, I think.
In that situation.
He did.
Yeah.
Nice kick.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Fuck.
Square.
Got it.
Nice.
That's a professional King player.
Hell yeah.
Definitely scared of the King grab.
So ducking.
What skin is this, Kony?
It's Mario.
I don't know.
I just think he looks cool.
This is like 1996.
Yeah, I was going to say it's the 1990s.
I think he looks cool.
This is how I look like showing up at Summit.
This is me at Summit.
You know that.
This is your Evo?
He's got little ear holes with a hat.
I like the sweatpants.
I think he actually scrubs out, but it's still cute.
He looks like a TF2 scout.
What?
Oh my damn it.
I miss TF2 so much, too.
We have TF2 at home.
Marvel rivals.
Oh, yay.
That's true.
That's the offense.
Typical Reyna activity.
Round two.
Fight.
I'm going to try to find more ways to do that.
He's not ready for it.
Apparently, SageM and Steve said that's how Coney dresses.
What a hopkick.
What the fuck did that hopkick feel like?
One day I'll be able to do a hopkick.
Just like my coach.
Coach Coney.
Coach Coney, let's go.
He's just bullying.
Who grows a shoe, honestly?
Round three.
Fight.
Oh, that's a...
I thought that was a low.
But she did the duck.
Oh my god.
Reyna just got to hold back there.
You just have to block.
Okay.
Wow.
Oh.
Nice.
Good duck.
That's fair.
He's ready now.
Fight.
Okay, just ducking all the time.
Yeah.
That was just hopkicks.
Okay.
He's scared.
Yeah.
I mean, mixture exists.
Yeah, that happens.
It's okay.
We have another set.
The combos are crazy.
I hate this level, man.
Fuck.
Okay.
One more set.
Oh, he won from the ducks.
Yeah.
If you lost, couldn't you switch stage?
You can if you pick random if you want.
Oh, no.
We all just fine.
We ball.
Fight.
Oh, what a quest, dude.
Remember, if you block, don't launch it.
That's funny.
It's just hopkicks.
Yeah.
No.
He'll duck every time now.
We know this.
Yeah.
We gotta keep Dwanas.
There you go.
Nice.
Press the little button.
Oh, nice.
Fuck, dude.
Oh, my God.
Yes.
That was insane.
Alley kick.
Okay.
Oh, Jesus.
Rage.
Done deal.
Fight.
Nice nut shot.
Every time she does that, I'm like, okay, that's a low.
No, it's gonna be a mid every time.
Yeah.
He's doing it over and over, man.
It's the same fucking thing.
Fuck.
Dude, that didn't hit.
I keep thinking it's low.
Like, I'm going low.
She's just hitting mid.
Yeah.
That... okay.
I tried to grab.
You can also Rage Yard if they're being like that at the corner.
Rage Yard is very valid.
Oh.
That block.
Dude, they should have pressed there.
Fuck, man.
Nice.
What a fucking follow-up.
That's it.
What a combo.
Nice.
What a grab.
Get into your head.
Oh.
Guard break.
What the fuck was that?
Oh, nice.
Get it all.
Get it all, man.
That was crazy.
That was weird.
I didn't mean to do that parry.
I tried to do back three.
Just Rage Yard there.
Dude.
Hopkick out.
You hit her?
Just hopkick.
Yeah.
Trying to do back out.
Playing frustrated.
Yeah, that's alright.
Locking, locking.
This guy is just one thing.
It's okay.
Now that you know that, you can use it for next time.
For the one with more points.
Yeah.
I just need more time.
I thought, I kept thinking it would change.
It's just one fucking thing over and over.
Okay.
Alright.
It's cool.
Doki won, right?
Yeah, I won.
You forgot I won?
That was some hype shit.
No, I am.
No, it was hype.
I just wanted to make sure.
You just wanted to make sure it wasn't a fluke.
What are you playing against?
Oh, shit.
I played this guy yesterday.
Didn't you win?
You made like a comeback.
But I think it was definitely matchup gap for him.
And I think he probably is coming correct.
That's okay.
If he wins, then it will be the same story, but like the other way.
If he silently enters me, I will be in trouble.
For real?
You come back one to challenge it if you want.
If he hits you into it, then just eat the mix.
The mid, it heat engages.
The low, just leads into another mix.
If he dynamically enters me, I think I will be okay.
That's not how I was working it.
Why?
That's what it is.
Dynamic entry and silent entry.
Yeah, you are right.
Either way, I am getting entered.
Well, do running 1 plus 2s into the hunting bear grab or anything.
Condition this man.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
He is naked too.
Don't get distracted like me.
Is that Shadow the hedgehog?
No way.
I think it is.
His Sonic is the other one.
Oh, my God.
It's Shadow.
He was Shadow last time I thought.
Or no, he was Sonic.
Wow, he is breaking doubles.
Oh, we can't break that.
Be careful.
He might bring a gun.
Holy fuck.
What a kick.
Good grab.
Oh.
Nice block.
Oh, nice.
I am playing autopilot.
I need to fucking lock in.
That was sloppy as shit.
Let's go.
I think he is also autopiloting a little bit.
A primitive mix up.
You can forward 2-1 that launcher he is trying.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
That was close.
That was a close twin piston.
Lock in.
Mix it up.
Nice.
Okay.
Look at that damage.
Good shit.
Nice.
Let's go.
Oh, I am dead.
No.
Remember that.
That is safe, right?
Oh, no.
Not even close.
I was looking at his health bar.
Or my health bar, not his.
Good lord.
Oh, my God.
The block, block, block, block.
Nice, dude.
Oh, my God.
Called it too.
He was not ready for you to take that.
He hit the whole tank.
Hell, yeah.
Nice.
Oh.
I got him.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
You don't even need the delay.
You don't even need it.
Woo.
One more, bro.
Let's go.
We believe.
Who painted that for him?
Did he go to a clown?
What the fuck?
Yeah, he knows a clown.
What a quick punch.
Sick.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Back up.
He's going to throw it out.
Okay.
Hello, Perry.
Hello, Perry this.
Dude, I'm mad.
Okay, it's fine.
I could have fucking had that round.
Let's do it.
Come on, baby.
What's up?
What?
Literally passed through his body.
Sorry.
We just want to give him a little bit.
Just give him one.
Oh, nice.
Yes, sir.
Oh, lots of damage.
I'm trying to get too cute, man.
It's okay.
We're keeping close for content.
It's cool.
We want to pad out the 10 minutes on the YouTube video.
Nice.
What the fuck is he doing?
What the fuck is he doing, man?
It's such a lame fucking character.
Oh, God.
Okay, next time you're ever put in rage, I promise you he's not looking for it.
Just smash it.
Like, you don't even have to think.
Just mash rage art if you have that red health bar.
I promise you it'll hit.
And when you get the wall, you can just do back 2-1 into the butt.
So you don't have to worry about the delay or anything.
Oh, nice.
That's punishable, though.
Okay.
Yeah, slap him!
Juggle him!
Rage art?
Nice!
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Good shit.
Save that read for the win.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Don't stop that combo!
What was that?
Okay, he's not wearing shoes.
It's gonna hurt.
Who glued him to the wall?
How's the Tekken 4 ass combo?
Do that again!
I am impressed.
I'm mad.
Oh, that was...
That would have cooked.
Oh, nice!
Nice!
Holy shit!
Oh, damage!
Send him into the moon!
Make the ground?
Oh, shit.
Got him.
It's okay.
Nice!
What the fuck?
What was that being?
Dude, that is very...
Oh, disrespectful!
Oh, my God!
Slime!
That is extremely disrespectful.
Let's go.
Who taught you that?
Let's fucking go.
Who taught you that and can I do it too?
You killed the vibes, man!
You killed the vibes!
Let's fucking go.
The chat said, fuck you, slime.
Shifter in the chat!
In the chat over there.
On the main broadcast too!
Let's fucking go.
I need his team's reaction to that.
Was that intentional?
That's very funny.
100%, yeah.
I thought you fucked up an input.
Oh, my God.
Now do that again.
Get him, Jack.
They're roasting me on commentary?
What?
How dare they?
They're saying I taught you that.
Or whatever.
Yeah, I got it on my repute that someone kicked you.
I mean, they're right.
It was all Brawl Pro's fault.
Can't believe you would do such a thing, Brawl Pro.
What about the integrity?
Oh, he kicked it.
Wow,
that was loud.
Oh, my God.
Nice.
Clean round.
Nice!
Hell yeah.
So clean.
Oh, launch.
Gonna hit the ceiling.
Oh!
Nice.
I can't believe we got this guy on our team again.
This is crazy.
See?
Run it back.
That's how it worked out, dude.
I think ZayJamp just didn't want to pay for more Evo trips.
Yeah, well, give him Jack these days.
I wanna get the cool combo.
Should I fucking farm for it?
No!
Oh, he had to disrespect doing.
I'll be the devil on your shoulders.
Yeah, do it.
Do it.
We're down by one currently.
Clip, clip, clip, clip.
Alright, I'm checking.
Check it, check it.
Where is it?
Oh, my God!
ZayJ had two levels.
What?
Where's another one?
Is there a third level?
Dude, that's really crazy.
It was so fucking worth it.
It was so worth it.
The content.
Holy shit.
That was unreal.
Oh, my God.
I've never seen that.
Yeah, we played with a little stank on it.
That was insane.
That was the fucking thing.
Oh, launch.
Hit the ceiling.
Nice.
Do it again.
Run it back.
This is insane.
No matter how many times I watch it, the screen is just shaking.
What the fuck, man?
That's perfect.
What do you do against this?
Atlas hammer.
Well, that's not Atlas hammer.
I think this is the most unlucky matchup for this person.
Oh, shit.
Nice gunner.
Oh, my God.
They got the hit in.
That's dirty.
Nice.
The perfect run is over.
Oh.
Nice.
Someone's nervous.
He got hit.
He doesn't know what to do.
Oh, my God.
You're so annoying.
You're annoying, dude.
You're annoying.
That is so annoying.
For a read.
She's still alive, though.
No way.
We're spring kicking into chat.
That's not gonna do it.
Round three.
The read.
Blast off.
She's in her PC reading the inputs.
God, dude.
That was good.
Oh.
Yo, round two.
Round two.
Do it again.
Do the combo.
Yes.
No way.
Oh, my God.
It's okay.
We already got one of it for the video.
Dude.
Nice.
Nice job.
Did he quit on me, bro?
What the fuck?
Oh, fuck.
Gifter.
You were.
It's tournament, man.
He left.
Oh, no.
Why?
Because I made a read?
I told you you were playing annoying.
I said you were playing mad annoying.
You are not fun to play with.
That's fine.
That's the goal.
Oh, my God.
Did he actually leave?
That's insane.
He left.
That's fucking crazy.
Oh, my God.
You hit me with that, I'm leaving the lobby and I'm uninstalling.
I'll ask for a steam refund.
I'm not playing this shit anymore.
We need a last minute replacement.
Oh, my God.
I did it, guys.
He actually plugged in the round robin.
He said, Matt, man.
Yeah.
What's up, bro?
GG's, man.
Hope to see you at EVO, dude.
You're posting?
How?
Because I optimized?
What?
He's being so toxic.
Dumb fuck.
I hope to see you at EVO, bro.
I'm on his side.
I'll shake your hand at EVO, man.
Hope to see you there.
That's Chandelier.
How can I focus after what's happened?
I feel like we should get extra points for making somebody plug.
I mean, like, for real, though.
Oh, shit.
Rob, bro, focus up.
How?
Do you see what's going on?
But how?
If I can play while distracted, so can you.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Maybe not.
Oh.
He did.
Come on, you got this.
I don't know what his habits are.
I guess we'll figure them out here.
We're doing it live.
Doing it live.
All in all.
Hmm.
What?
I'm telling y'all.
It's just Rage Arts, dude.
I'm just saying, man.
It's funny that the coaches are doing it way more than anyone else.
Just rip it, bro.
You're right, bro.
Fucking rip it.
It's all about the wins.
Consider it like armor, but it also armor blows.
Oh, nice.
Oh, my God.
Big tummy ache.
Nice.
Ouch.
Oh, my God.
Chill.
Relax.
Give him another turn.
Put him down, bro.
It's his turn.
Samuel L.
Jackson comes in.
Put that young woman down.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Dude, are you serious?
Nice.
Oh, my God.
He's locking it in.
You go, coach.
Second coach.
The side coach.
Go, coach.
Coach B.
It's like a summer camp.
Yeah, yeah.
Substitute teacher.
Nice.
Oh, good break.
Oh, this guy's paying attention to everything.
Oh.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Surely.
This little kid is showing it.
Okay, I was gonna say.
Break the window.
Nice.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Does he got a mega combo?
Well.
Oh, my God.
He broke two windows.
Processing combo.
Nice.
What a fucked up stage.
Oh, my God.
They got nukes in the sun room.
Oh, this is where Jackie's built.
Yeah.
When would they expect it?
Dude, everything's exploding.
Where is the safety?
There's no OSHA here.
This thing's crazy.
I think King has four clips there, though.
Oh, nice.
Oh, my God.
Oh, who?
Oh, no.
What in the fuck?
Oh.
Oh,
the brakes.
How the fuck did you break that?
Yeah.
You just pushed her off.
Nice.
Oh.
That's right.
Keep being close for the YouTube video.
Dude.
Nice.
So many moves.
Round four.
Fight.
Please stop.
Oh.
Perfect.
I know.
Muhammad Ali.
The dodges, too.
Oh.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
The damage.
Okay.
Dead?
Oh, is she dead?
Yeah.
He's strong.
Fight.
What?
Platform again.
He did a four there.
Damn it.
Oh.
How the fuck did that wall blast?
That's crazy.
Imagine.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, good.
No.
It's so close.
His enlarged steroid heart finally exploded.
.
All right.
Dude, if we sweep this one, that'd be such a good cap off to the day.
So, no pressure, Unc, but all the pressure.
Unfortunately, I lost.
You can't sweep it.
Wait, you did?
I was thinking that, too.
Yeah.
Everyone's just going to remember the combo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everybody's just going to remember that.
No, look, we can lie.
You got your moment.
Yeah, I really did.
If we think we sweeped it, the fans will think we sweeped it.
We just changed the narrative.
Yeah, change the narrative.
Only the winners write in history, and we're winning.
Oh, shh.
Oh, god.
That's crazy.
How did she miss that?
All right, through.
Ernesto?
Oh!
You threw?
What do you mean?
How did you know that was...
Is it 12 frame?
You're a freak.
The...
Azucena's backswing, where she, like, evades, is launch punishable.
Oh, wow.
Most backswings in the game.
Oh, god!
Read her fucking mind!
He was ready.
Oh, my god!
Oh!
Let's go!
Good stage, bro!
Pizza Hut manager.
Oh, my god.
This is what it's like to block.
Nice.
It is a nair, yeah.
Just pressure.
Sometimes you're just wrong.
Yeah.
How was that not counter-hit?
I don't know.
She's on the Wi-Fi.
What the...
Oh, he's nice.
That was a good block, though.
Oh!
Good stuff!
He's ducking hard.
He knows.
Oh, that's close.
Oh, here we go, bro.
Let's go, baby.
Wrap it up.
Nice!
Nice.
Good shit.
Damn it.
Aw.
That's unfortunate.
Oh, god!
So close!
Into the window!
Nice.
GG.
Pretty good.
Good player, bro.
Good player.
That was a toughie.
Still 3-2, though.
Yeah, 3-2.
We won it.
We were positive on most of our matches, if not all.
I'm looking at the scoreboard.
I don't know if it's updated, but...
Well, I think they're still playing.
MYK is first at 14.
We didn't get updated yet, but...
We're at 12.
So if we went 3-2, I think we're...
We're 15.
Wait, so we first?
So we're first unless Hidetone...
Yeah, we're first unless Hidetone...
sweeps.
Wait, have they finished their game yet?
Or if they 4-1.
Because Hidetone is 11.
KFM is 7, so I don't think they can hit us no matter what.
But...
Yeah, so we're at 15.
If Hidetone goes 4-1, we tie.
Oh, okay.
So we...
Hey, that's really good!
We might have won.
Yeah, honestly, that's sick.
Especially for like...
We didn't practice as much.
Yeah.
Seriously.
We're not even in the tournament, bro.
Well, didn't you start your practice like yesterday, Koni?
Yes.
I played a lot the first time.
This time, I'm like, it's day one.
It's just learning.
I'm not, you know... I didn't take it as seriously.
Good shit, guys.
Alright, let's call it a day.
Does anyone know what Hidetone did?
I don't know.
Is he on stream?
Yeah, chat.
Stream site.
How well did Hidetone did?
Where's my stream snipers?
3-2?
They were saying 3-2 in my chat.
If it's 3-2, then we're first.
Yeah, we're first.
Because we're 15.
Was that the last one?
Yeah, that's it.
We were on stream for the last one.
Yeah.
Oh, cool.
Yeah, we won.
We won the day.
Good shit, fellas!
Yeah!
We did it!
We won the day?
Yeah!
And if people try to download me, I'm only at 1% of my level right now.
I'm using the scoreboard.
I don't know...
It hasn't been updated for KFM or Tone.
But it doesn't matter.
Because they can't reach us.
Hidetone, if he went 3-2, is 14 also.
Yeah.
And we're 15.
They're probably gonna look at match counts after that.
Woo!
Good shit, fellas!
Yeah, guys!
We did it!
Okay!
Donkey, very proud of you for the 2 Ws.
Let's go!
I practiced good shit.
I beat a red, guys!
Hold on.
I have a...
I have a shifter clip.
Wait.
Oh!
George Bush, PNG.
SirJune has hit a second wall.
Hold on.
Oh, god, dude.
Here you go, chat.
That's fucking awesome.
Dude, there's still 15 more seconds in the clip.
Oh, my god!
Bro, he's coping so hard!
Nice.
That was good, though.
We got a ragequit clip and everything.
That was pretty good.
I feel him, man.
I'm on his side.
Jack looks annoying as shit.
That looks obnoxious.
That one combo was ridiculous.
I don't even...
Oh, I can't... He was coping so hard.
Wait, did CJM end?
Yeah, he did.
Oh, he just ended the stream.
That's it.
I mean, shit, we're done.
We did.
No, fucking relax.
Take a break.
That was kind of fast.
Okay.
Recuperate.
Alright, fellas, we won!
Good shit, everybody!
We did it!
First day!
We won again.
RawProTeam on top.
We're running back in round two!
Yeah, so...
I'm gonna drive home and then I can review some of your guys' stuff and we can talk about everything, like, tomorrow or later tonight.
So we're ready for the day after.
Yeah.
Yeah!
I'm gonna hop in with you and get some...
I need some help.
Yeah, and the thing is, it's very easy to identify.
It's super easy to identify the shortcomings, you know what I mean?
I think we all have extremely easy shit to, like, I don't know.
I trust you guys to adapt harder, you know what I mean?
Like, I'm not...
I'm confident.
You guys are sick.
I mean, Doki only needs to learn mids, does he?
Yeah, I just need to learn other combos and... I never expected!
And to hit the leg drop after the kick, you know?
Yeah.
Very simple fine-tuning for our machine.
That's all I need.
Good shit, everybody.
I'm so proud.
It's so good to be back, bro.
Now I'm gonna unpack my new PC tomorrow so I won't lag.
Easy.
Oh, true.
We hit everything.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
We're gonna make it.
We're gonna make it to EVO.
We're going to... well, you're gonna make it easy.
Yeah, I'm gonna make it to EVO.
You can come see us, you know what I'm saying?
Alright, I'm down to practice maybe late tonight but definitely tomorrow.
Sound good?
Yeah, yeah.
Tonight I'll be with this scuffed mic but yeah, I'm down.
Alright, brother.
Take care, everybody.
I'll see you guys soon.
GG's, guys!
GG!
Road to EVO.
Bye-bye!
Oh my god.
I couldn't find the fucking hang up button just then.
Oh my god!
Guys!
We did so well!
As a baby we got first place!
I can't believe it!
I beat two players!
I beat a red!
That man was ten ranks above me!
And I knew like two combos... I barely knew a combo to be fair.
I only knew three moves and I beat a red!
And I beat a fellow king main!
And she's been playing king and tekken far longer than me!
And I did it while talking!
I did it while being distracted!
Guys!
I wasn't focused up!
I fucking did that shit with no thoughts in my head!
It's all about instincts and pressing the square!
Guys!
They can't analyze me!
I barely have anything to analyze!
The yadding is channeled into kinks.
Oh my god.
I actually did not expect to win any games at all to be fair!
I went in!
I was so nervous!
I was so scared!
I was like... well I wasn't like scared!
I was just like... I'm just going in with just to have fun Doki!
Just to have fun!
There's no way you're gonna win any of these matches!
They're so good!
Everybody's been grinding longer than me!
And then I won two!
And I got a I got a round off SK!
And that's all that matters!
Did I get two rounds?
I got two rounds off SK!
I was so happy!
I don't know if SK if she was like playing nice to me or anything.
I don't know if she was like being nice to me in the first two rounds.
But like I take those!
I take those!
Cause she has like a hundred plus hours.
I have like 10 to 15.
I have I have a bunch of matches!
Oh my god!
It's crazy!
I had a lot of fun guys!
Just so you guys know this is round robin one.
We got we got like one... we got first place on day one.
There's two more days.
There's round robin two.
And then there's the finals.
So we have two more days.
Finals is on Sunday.
That's why it's not on my schedule.
But we're in first place!
We got first!
Yeah!
I've been streaming for four...
This does not feel like four hours.
I really like my teammates.
I really like Slimeconey, BrawPro, and Madman.
They were so fucking hype.
Our team was totally the vibes team.
Cause we're all just talking all the time.
And I love that.
I love that.
We're not like taking it super seriously.
But we're still winning.
Even though we weren't taking it super seriously, we were still winning.
We were yapping all the time too.
Um... yeah.
My favorite part was when I was like, eat his ass!
And I don't remember who it was.
It was like with a spoon!
I don't even know who said that.
The content team.
Grab a spoon.
Scoop it up!
And then...
I was like, they're like, won!
And so it was like, hold square!
I was like, square!
I know what square is!
But yeah.
Had a great time.
I had a great...
I had a great time with everybody.
Hey guys!
I'm gonna call it here!
I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
As always everyone, stay hydrated, pause to check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!